Oh Shits.
We pitches.
Here we are again.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you.
This episode is brought to you by Hover,
If you go to hover.com forward slash,
Rogan,
you will get 10% off of your domain name.
I got to fuck an ant on my computer.
Note how I squash ants and throw them to the table with no regard.
You know why?
Because there's so much smaller than me that I can't be bothered.
But any bigger than that,
you got to clean it up like you get to a roach.
All right,
now you've got a problem,
but an aunt,
no,
I crushed that bitch and that will continue with my conversation as if nothing
happened.
While it's eviscerated,
body smushed beneath my giant fingers just lies there rotting on the Oak table,
hover.com forward slash rug and you will get 10% off of your domain name
registrations.
And a hover is a company that's owned by the same people that own ting.
And if you know how we feel about ting,
it's the same way we feel about Hubbard.
Their approach is they're trying to be a non evil domain name company.
Is that funny?
It's much,
yeah.
Nobody gives a fuck about ants man.
You know,
even vegans step on an ant,
they got to do what they gotta do.
However,
believes that,
uh,
you know,
there's a lot of shit that is not attached to a most domain name registration.
That should be like,
I'm like,
who is privacy sub domains and a URL forwarding stuff that you have to pay for a
lot of places have or things that you should she get that Shit for free?
Should be.
It's the same approach that they have to Tang.
They,
they're,
they're taking that same approach and a using it for domain names.
So if you want to register a domain name,
please go to hover h,
o,
v,
e r and if you go to hover.com forward slash Rogen,
you will save yourself some kids,
Ash,
son,
go there and get your paper.
Save yourself 10% off any of your donor domain name registrations.
We were also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com we drinking some on it.com
bulletproof coffee cause we started carrying it because it's the shit.
Uh,
you uh,
appreciate it.
Tim Ferris,
do you realize the difference between this and the micro toxin filled coffee
that you drink every day?
I just feel like I have an ivy of MCT oil feeding my brain.
It's fantastic.
Problem is it coats your mouth though sometimes and it gives you a little phlegm
catfish breath.
Yeah.
You're,
you're having some issues with the stimulants
affection but this is that what I have a yeast infection.
Goddamn it,
they smelled like tuna and I was worried about that.
Yeah.
And that kind of fish though.
Not Kidding.
Why Catfish?
I don't know.
My girlfriend said I smelled like death sweats earlier,
so I smelled like cat fish cause I was experimenting with Bacopa plus Grapesy,
a grapefruit seed extract and some of the stimulants to see how it extended the
effects.
But I just had this thought that catfish,
we will get all,
we're going to get down to that.
We're going to have to get to the bug to that,
go to [inaudible] dot com forward slash go fuck yourself because there's no
forward slash she used to name rogue and you'll save 10% off.
But uh,
we carry a lot of cool shit.
Now a 10% off any of all supplements if used code name Brogan a,
it doesn't work for the fitness equipment,
but it's because we sell it as cheap as humanly possible.
We started carrying kettlebells,
battle ropes,
medicine balls,
uh,
basically all functional strength stuff,
all the types of things I would be into.
If you are really interested in on it,
go to go to the website and check it out.
Or if you really want to go in depth,
you can listen to the podcast that we had was two podcasts ago with Aubrey
Marcus who is the,
uh,
the CEO and a business partner and on it.
And he's um,
he's an awesome dude and his,
his idea and the way he's running the company,
it's very admirable.
The whole idea behind it is sell people the best shit possible.
Find the best ingredients,
sell that and sell it at a reasonable rate.
We sell a lot of shit like we sell Blendtec blenders,
$200 less than the manufactured suggested retail price.
We just try to sell you shit that is like really good effective stuff for your
health.
Whether it's a hemp force protein powder or whether it's Alpha brain,
which is a cognitive enhancing supplement that I fucking swear by it.
I don't do podcasts without it.
I think you need nutrients folks.
It's important.
Keep your fucking Nog and fed.
Keep your body healthy.
Am I right Tim Ferriss fucking a year,
right?
What does a battle rope,
that's my question.
Battle ropes are these big giant ship yard ropes and the lady said Ro,
Oh rose [inaudible] when I go to the bathroom it's like a weighted bathroom.
I was like,
cause that will cross cross fit
bad idea.
I mean they have weighted vests.
How about a whole weighted outfit?
Will you've got to move your whole body with like weighted arms and shit.
I bet.
So it'd be a good workout and they'd probably come up with some reason why it
works.
We'll proportionately,
when you carry weights,
it's not right because your weight,
the extra week should be distributed through your whole body in order for you to
gain mathematics,
mathematical,
athletic inputs.
You want to start wearing armor is weight our army,
your army,
when is have them start wearing armor.
Say that if you were trying to harm or you'd be stronger the on it on the Rogan
plate.
Male line.
I don't think that's a bad idea.
This is a good way to introduce the idea of wearing armor.
So the government's thought like,
what the fuck are you preparing for?
The God of ropes.
Hey,
we're trying to work out.
We're crossfitters were all peaceful and Scott is a Vegan and I grass
fed
battle ropes are these gigantic ropes that you swing for endurance.
So fucking awesome.
Yeah,
I do these wild 32nd sprints with them.
It's,
it's so applicable for Jujitsu,
kickboxing,
anything physical.
It's cause it's,
you're moving this awkward weight over,
you know,
and you know,
30 foot,
40 foot length and whipping it back and forth.
Have you ever seen a Zach [inaudible]?
No.
What's that?
Oh,
he's a,
he's a trainer out of New Jersey.
I said,
well,
let me just congratulate him on his bad ass name.
That's a great name.
What's his name again?
Zappa.
Nash Esch.
Evan.
That's a pretty great finish.
Yes.
H and he,
uh,
name Zach an ish?
Yeah.
Ooh.
It's like a duck.
Sounds like a Dothraki.
Does
anyone he uses ropes.
He's a beast.
Oh yeah.
Ropes are awesome,
man.
Medicine balls.
Another thing I've been using a lot lately.
Uh,
I just,
uh,
I just hired a trainer two months ago for the first time ever.
I mean,
I've used guys before.
I've trained was like Steve Maxwell,
but I've never used a guy every week on a regular basis over and over and over
again until I started using this one guy.
And we're doing a lot of wacky shit.
How'd you choose him?
Why did you choose the,
his name's Justin.
These are my Jujitsu class.
He's a,
it was a high level wrestler,
division one wrestler,
really talented athlete and uh,
just one school for it and is really passionate about it and watching them
train.
And I was like,
these motherfuckers never tired.
So I went to him.
I'm like,
what are you doing for training?
Because we're,
you know,
when you're training me,
he's,
he's a brown belt.
You're training,
we're talking about,
he's training with black belts.
Who trained with Eddie Bravo is training with,
you know,
a lot of the killers that they have a 10th planet.
And I'm looking at this kid's in Dorrance.
I'm like,
I'm really impressed.
It was like fourth,
fifth role and he's got going at a high clip.
I'm like,
you're doing something like,
what are you doing?
He's like a lot of kettle bells,
a lot of body weights,
this and then he goes,
I'm a trainer.
So I just started working out with them.
Cool.
So I had been doing a lot of it on my own before.
But it,
man,
it makes a big difference when you,
when you work out with somebody just fucking,
it makes you a division one.
Wrestlers are mutants.
Incredibly incredible.
He's got a lot of uh,
great ideas too that came along like while,
I mean he's young kid,
he's like 26 so while he was learning like a lot of liquid in the last two
decades,
they've made some huge strides when it comes to the actual work versus the
actual result.
Like what's overtraining,
what's,
you know,
heart rate monitors necessary,
what's,
what's going,
let's mad at monitor the your entire system instead of just pushing you.
Because there was a lot of like nonsense just pushing you in the past and they
sort of narrowed it down to a science and the kids that are coming up now,
they're going through like good division one schools.
They know what the fuck they're doing when they're training these kids.
Oh yeah.
They're like professional teams.
And it's what's been fascinating too,
is that he looked at the vast majority of research on athletic performance over
the last,
let's say 50 years.
Most of it is in 45 minute or 90 minute intervals.
So they had to design experiments that would allow people to say exercise for
that period of time because what is that?
It's a college,
it's the length of a college class.
And they were recruiting college students to participate as subjects for most of
these.
In other words,
they didn't actually have the funding to study,
let's say the effect of 32nd sprints on a robot capacity.
Like there's a fantastic research and invite Gibala gib a la who's looked at how
you could do two to three minutes if cumulative sprint time and increase your
capacity or endurance as much as let's
say four to six hours of steady state training per week.
Why isn't that crazy?
Yeah,
it's amazing.
And I actually started playing around with it like 120%,
uh,
Max vo two on a stationary bike for,
so very similar to Tabata protocol,
but you're taking let's say 32nd sprints.
And what I ended up doing was just taking very long rest intervals,
32nd sprint long rest in a role almost as a long,
I would do perhaps six.
Oh,
are you talking about the rest period?
I would rest two to three minutes.
I do the exact same thing I do.
Oh,
I do less rest time.
I do 30 seconds on,
30 seconds off.
Yeah.
And I've been doing that for a while.
On a elliptical,
full clip.
On an elliptical.
Yeah.
A and,
and it's,
it's just incredible when you start to see money coming into this research.
Partially because the technology like wearable sensors and accelerometers and
all of this are becoming big business.
Like if Nike plus and whatnot.
So there's a lot,
there's a lot more cash than has ever been available for athletic performance
enhancement.
Dude,
I just realized we're still in the middle of the commercial.
Oh.
And and I t use a code name Brogan,
save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right.
We just dropped some knowledge in the middle of a commercial.
Let's start this bitch.
Tim Ferriss has too much information.
It's filling out
[inaudible]
called the Tim Ferris.
You were dropping so much knowledge
and it was in the middle of a commercial.
That's how,
that's how bad ass you are.
I just got them a 10 minute commercial.
Yeah.
The,
this you said that you were smelling like catfish because you were taking
certain stimulants.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't,
uh,
well I've been playing around with a few different smart drugs.
I got it out of smart drugs for a long time because like I mentioned before we
get started.
I just don't think there is a biological free lunch.
So if you see a really strong effect,
whether you can identify the side effect or not,
I think there's an equal amplitude of seismic height of,
well,
let's just be real about what we're talking about because it's,
both of us have kind of skirted around the issue.
It's,
it's,
I have definitely,
it's called provigil.
Provigil,
you know,
we found,
I found out about it because,
uh,
Dave Asprey,
who I was incredibly impressed with came on the podcast and talked about
anything and everything and um,
was just,
he had so much energy and then someone sent me this message like,
oh,
the guy does pro vigil,
like go check it out.
Like he's,
he's on speed.
Oh,
okay.
I'm like,
well that makes sense to the guy was like,
but he didn't seem speedy.
So I'm like,
okay,
that's weird.
Cause he didn't seem like,
you know,
there's people that seem,
they're weird.
Like you're talking to him.
Like there's,
you're missing the energy of this room.
You're,
you're,
you're overstepping your awkward timing.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Timing issue there.
They're wacky,
you know,
he wasn't like that.
It was completely in the moment.
So what he discussed,
he said,
I wasn't,
I'm pro vigil when I was there.
I actually don't take it anymore,
but I did take it every day for almost eight years with great benefit.
And I was like,
Oh wow,
whoa.
What?
Like,
what are you taking?
So I tried it and I tried it in the first time I tried,
I was like,
Holy Shit,
this is real.
Wow.
Cause it's not unlike coffee.
Okay.
And it's not like being high.
It's some weird thing,
some weird thing where you're like fucking sharp as Shit,
you know?
And it lasts for like five or six hours and I only took a half of one of these
little fuckers.
It wasn't even like a full one and a I was,
I was really shocked.
And then the first thing I thought of is wow,
now I know why people are reluctant to tell people about this stuff because
there'll be eating it like candy.
And that's exactly what you said.
That's why I omitted it.
But and
so pro vigil,
which is Modafinil,
I actually first heard about,
well before it became popular with say Ceos because sprinters,
we're using it Olympic sprinters and they were getting prescriptions and false
diagnoses from doctors as narcoleptics because it was anti narcolepsy drug so
that if they got caught it could be inadvertent use and they'd be like,
but I'm a narcoleptic Olympic sprinter.
Like,
right.
Sure.
You are.
Imagine that full sprint and then face the middle of a stride.
Greatest Olympics ever.
They're like,
it would be like controversy because the guy takes modafinil.
Does that actually help us?
Well,
he needs it.
He has an arc elliptic we know it.
We have footage of him from the 2014 games where he face planted.
So there are different,
this is a side note,
but I've had enough shit in my system by now that I'll just digress at will be,
uh,
have you ever seen the videos of narcoleptic goats that fall asleep?
If they're startled,
they're amazing.
They need more provincial.
But the,
uh,
I've been experimenting with a smart drugs which have been very hesitant to do,
for a long time because it's very seductive and easy to get hooked on them.
Provigil or fennel Prasad,
Tim,
uh,
press temps or the Ras at Tams or class of smart drugs really considered kind of
the granddaddies of the category.
I never found pressed him to do much.
I tried oxy asked him and harass temo number of derivatives,
fennel,
prs,
tams 30 to 60 times more stimulatory.
So it's popular with cyclists,
like Tour de France,
cyclists.
Did you ever try porosity them with Coleen?
Yep.
So this is the,
yeah,
this is,
this is just as the key yet you need to combine it with Coleen.
So when I've used fennel press tam recently,
I'd combine it with,
with Coleen.
What is the difference?
So can you,
can you describe it?
How it's,
cause I haven't done this,
I just,
just what I've read,
well it's,
I think that where people,
and this is where the biological fleet for a free lunch or the myth thereof
comes into play.
If you're using a stimulant,
say that is forcing your brain to burn,
given neurotransmitter's at a faster rate,
you're going to deplete your gas tank.
So you need a means to regenerate that.
And Coleen is,
uh,
along with other things,
it can be helpful for producing,
let's say acetylcholine.
And,
uh,
so that is why in many cases,
well this is one case where you're providing a precursor and then something like
fennel pressed him,
which acts on culinary kick receptors.
You can also do that,
uh,
certainly with a different types of physical training.
So if you look at people who tip might take,
let's say,
uh,
I'm trying to think of a good example.
Um,
thyroid hormone,
like t three or any number of things.
If you combine that,
then with higher protein intake,
you're going to see better results,
right?
And it's very similar,
but you're just applying it to the organ of the brain.
Um,
other smart drugs to,
to,
I'm sorry to interrupt you,
but to keep the reserves from being depleted too badly,
you have to oversupply certainly.
At least you have to increase your supply.
Uh,
and what,
what,
what specifically like in this case,
Coleen is helping you to produce the neurotransmitters that are affected by the
drug that you're using.
In this case,
a federal Prasadam.
Uh,
I've fallen out of the loop with a lot of this,
but got back into it because a friend of mine who's a,
he's a,
he's a computer hacker who a lot like frank abignail from catch me if you can.
He was basically told you can go to jail or you can help the government to
identify like a weaknesses in their systems.
And he's a,
he is a,
uh,
an explorer of smart drugs.
And he turned me on to specifically the combination of artichoke extract and
Forskolin and these used in combination effect cyclical and p and all sorts of
things.
But it,
yeah,
so this is something you can get over the counter that has very similar,
the by the,
the actual mechanism of action might be different,
but for me it gave a very similar effect to modafinil real,
the feeling itself.
The problem was that I needed 12 to 14 hours of sleep that night,
or I couldn't function the next day.
Wow.
Which tells me my body needs to regenerate something that I'm depleting clearly.
Uh,
the,
what I'd just like to point out to people who might be like,
Holy Shit,
let me order some stuff from some European pharmacies,
the podcast,
they're all the same before the podcast.
They're not going to listen to you.
I know they won't.
They won't,
but I'll tell you anyway,
which is,
I,
I'm very conservative with taking some of these drugs that affect the brain,
particularly because if you look at medicine in general,
they're plenty of drugs that have been,
uh,
had supposedly had no side effects.
Statens thalidomide for instance,
which resulted in horrific birth defects that,
that,
that aren't seen or I should say,
concluded to have side effects until five,
10,
15 years down the line.
So it's like whatever you do,
at the very least,
cycle off every once in a while,
especially for the mind.
Right?
I mean,
the mind is such a tricky thing.
The,
it's so sensitive.
It's you,
are you aware of reequip?
No,
this is a great case.
They a Parkinson's medication.
Okay.
That turned a guy into a gay sex addict.
He was completely straight with kids.
Okay.
One $600,000 from glaxosmithkline.
Yeah.
So I mean that's a gigantic pharmaceutical company with pretty fucking bad ass
lawyers.
Okay.
So for this guy to actually go to court and win more than a half a million
dollars because they turned them into a gay sex and gambling addict.
You think though like he do you think he was alone but I can know what I wanted.
Combination.
Yeah.
Gambling case.
Wonder what else he didn't file for.
He was apparently just nuts for thrills.
Like he was like,
like anything like really fucked up are really crazy and dangerous.
So we put out like,
um,
like ads in like,
uh,
like papers,
like you know,
the public,
you know,
what are,
what are those a meetup ads and hook up ads,
like Craig's list type thing and just was getting raped by guys.
I mean he,
he was doing it.
I mean he like,
he was crazy.
It was real.
And he was gambling like couldn't stop gambling.
I mean,
could you imagine you were regular fucking guy?
I have a little Parkinson's map docs,
my hands shaking.
I don't know what to do.
Trust me.
This is the medication for you.
We're going to give you this and you're going to be all fixed up and then all of
sudden he wakes up playing poker in a gay orgy sucking cocks.
It throwing money on the table.
I mean their clinic let that,
he probably didn't even know what he was doing.
That's the worst side effects ever.
Can you imagine the commercial make Mickey get butt raped by a bunch of million
and might make you suck cock and lose all your money?
Talk to your doctor.
It's,
I mean it's really a fascinating thing.
I've been trying to work it out on stage and talk about it,
but it's,
it's so,
it's so ridiculous that it doesn't even seem like it could be real.
Like the guy was a straight guy and he had two kids and then all of a sudden
he's a gambling and sex addict.
He said he was in gay orgies and shit.
He was playing play,
placing ads and like come fuck me.
You know like who wants to hook up?
And he would go play some catch,
just punch him and fuck him through.
It's like a regular guy.
And the idea is that the,
you know,
the powerful medication,
like something to treat Parkinson's somehow or another goes down the wrong alley
of the mind and says,
oh,
well let's look,
because we're going to shut this off.
Let's fucking turn this.
What are these over here?
What are these do?
Oh,
this is this the one that makes you love cock.
Let's hit that and see what he does.
Yeah,
man.
Just say no.
Kids just say no.
Say No to reequip.
By the way,
you know what else works for Parkinson's marijuana and that's illegal.
But that reequip shit.
You can go get it tomorrow.
I think they took it off the market.
I think once you lose a big one like that,
you'd probably go,
oh,
okay.
It might be something to this.
So to avoid,
right,
to avoid the,
uh,
if it's not your thing,
the gay orgies magic.
If it works on everybody,
imagine if all the other dudes that have Parkinson's,
we just keeping their mouth shut and this guy was the only guy I'll just fucking
getting raped to gamble.
I was money.
All the other guys had Parkinson.
So like I thought it was just a loser.
All of a sudden I thought it was a crazy gay loser.
Stick to the coconut oil and creatine.
Maybe like all of the people who took this [inaudible] sex junkies.
The rest of them just fought it off.
No,
no,
no gay sex.
This guy was just like,
fuck it,
let's just do this.
I just go with my feelings,
man.
You know,
I trust my spirit.
Rolling dice and blonde dudes.
Meanwhile I was just the drugs all along.
So this artichoke extract or took extract plus forskolin.
That's what Coleus forskohlii and
exactly what a stupid name for a drug that you want to take serious.
And I was like,
you couldn't make another noise with your mouth.
You have to make it sound like for skin,
you know?
It's like the word,
the word niggardly,
you know,
that's like an actual word that means stingy.
You know?
It's like if someone got in trouble for using it,
a guy got,
I check you in a college in the east coast for using it and they,
I guess they thought he was a smart ass because it's not really in the public
vernacular anymore and we kind of know what it,
what it really sounds like,
but the fact is it's actually a word,
you know,
please.
Yeah,
just,
it's just too close.
It's just,
sorry.
You know you can't use it,
but it's a different word.
It doesn't matter but doesn't work with some things.
You know,
like you can say pussy cat,
you can get a bit of pussy,
cat,
pussy,
cat.
I love my pussy cat.
Pussy cat.
Yeah.
See that's when you start getting sketchy when you're talking about wet pussy
catalysis.
Yeah.
I'm going to go,
I'm going to go put my hand on my wet pussy cat.
See,
you got your,
you're crossing the line.
You know you're,
you're getting,
you're getting graphic,
but you know what I mean.
It's like,
you can say that word,
but fuck doesn't exist anywhere.
You can't,
you can't stick that in there.
He can't say unfucking believable and everybody goes,
oh yeah,
but it's in the middle of all that other stuff.
That's okay.
Like pussy cat fuck is one of the most flexible words in the English language.
It's also replaces the word,
uh,
a lot,
fucking fucking guy.
But there's a right way to do it.
Right?
It's like unfucking believable,
but you can't say unbelievable fucking bowling.
It doesn't work.
Yeah.
There's a,
there's actually a little book,
it's like 80 pages long called English as a second fucking language and it talks
about the grammar of using the word fuck curse words and fucking whatnot.
It's very important.
I mean,
as a comedian,
one of the things that I learned early on,
um,
starting out in Boston especially,
they were very cognizant about the rhythm of comedy and the use of the word fuck
that if you over fucked,
like have you used it too much,
it would ruin your set and it would ruin that
word for the rest of the evening.
And so like,
when a guy would go up,
like me sucked,
I used the word fuck too much.
You know,
when I was in the beginning,
I would get like a lecture by one of the older guys who've been around for
awhile.
Like,
well kid,
you can use the word fuck but don't say fuck every other word.
But the idea is when you say you mean it's your throat and they'll be like,
oh okay.
So these guys,
you know,
and being comedians,
they were basically craftsmen with the English language.
I mean they were allowed,
a lot of them were blue collar guys.
A lot of them were,
you know,
they would have been carpenters if they weren't comedians,
but as Comedians,
the way they approached the craft of saying things sort of re re categorize the,
the idea of swear words to me.
Cause before it was just a natural thing to use them.
And I didn't realize how clunky my language was until I started doing standup
comedy.
If I remember,
I got really annoyed with myself for overusing the word pretty like oh that's
pretty good.
Oh it's pretty nice.
I feel pretty good.
I feel I got really annoyed.
But for,
for overusing that?
No,
I just,
I'm just like,
it's so fucking lazy then I use this all the time.
So I decided that I would cure myself of it by forcing myself in any company if
I use the word pretty to say fucking after.
So that's pretty fucking expensive.
[inaudible] I stopped,
I stopped.
It was tick that I had to hear it,
but I wanted to ask you when you're working on your material,
because I become kind of fascinated by standup,
uh,
how do you,
how do you work on writing your material out?
Does it longhand?
Is it just notes and then he tried to piece it together?
Like at what point,
at what point are you done enough with the material to actually get up and try
to put it in practice?
I do it in two separate ways.
I do either directly or indirectly.
And by indirectly I write a blog entry and then writing a blog entry and it
might start off with a,
you know,
something about food,
and then somewhere along the line it becomes something crazy.
Then I'll go in and cherry pick the craziness and the silliness and stuff that
makes me laugh.
It just comes out of nowhere.
And then I feel like,
and then I take that,
extract it and put it into another file and then that those become like
potential material ideas for beds.
But I feel like you have to,
one of the most important things about coming up with stuff,
especially when you're like under the gun,
is you have to show up.
You have to be there and you have to just put in enough time staring at that
screen and writing and just know that some of it is not going to be that good.
Some of it is going to be just noise and then boom,
you hit a vein and then you hit that vein and you might be able to ride that
vein for hours.
And then it just,
it just,
you have these new unique ideas that they weren't going to come unless you gave
massive amount of consideration to the idea.
And the problem with just sitting around trying to come up with ideas on your
own,
driving in your car,
like that is one way and sometimes you get things that way,
but when you're sitting in front of a computer and that's all you're doing,
you're just trying,
or a notepad if you like Longhand,
when you're,
you're actually just thinking about something,
then you're allowing the mind go off and all these little
branches.
Yeah,
so there's a lot of guys who don't write like in front of a computer or on a
pad,
the only come up with their material on stage.
They have ideas and they take those ideas and they'd go on stage them and then
that becomes like a form.
Once they figured out how to do it right,
then that becomes like the bit,
and then Zach does that required just a tremendous amount of,
of sort of natural gift in the same way that an athlete could go out and
improvise without training in the sense that someone who has such a fast mental
turnover that they can improvise on stage and make it entertaining even when
it's completely,
and it's a sort of fetal stage.
You,
you sorta,
but you don't even try it unless you think there's something there and there's
gotta be something there for you and you kind of recognize it and they're not
all gyms.
Right.
You know,
sometimes there's bits that have done that,
you know,
they might've worked once and they didn't work a second time or they didn't work
as well,
or there's something off.
So I pull it out of the lineup and I go,
you know,
and put you over here until I figure you out.
And then I'd go back to them and sometimes I'll go,
I'll,
I'll take them out of the lineup for a year.
You know it's have a text file that you put that into?
Sometimes.
Sometimes not.
Sometimes it's just in my memory there's certain bits that I'd never,
I've never written down because they came to me on stage and then I just carried
them on to the next and then they'll,
they'll grow to,
yeah.
Sometimes I forget them.
Yeah.
That's the words you think of the best new bit on stage and you just forget
about it.
Well that's why I record all my sets.
I always forget that they even listen to that,
but I don't know.
I don't forget that every single one.
Yeah,
you have to,
it's part of the job.
You have to,
you have to be a professional.
There's,
there's certain aspects of being a comedian that you have to be a professional
at.
One of them is you have to listen to sets.
If I have a new bit in the new bit came out in the set,
I listened to it and it's easy to do because I,
my Bluetooth phone hooks up to my car so I'm driving home.
I said is on my phone cause he used the voice memos for iTunes.
It's fine.
I can hear it.
Oh I need to do is hear it.
Right.
So that's in my car and I'm driving home and instead of like just playing music
and dicking around,
I can go over the new material.
So I'll,
I'll go,
okay.
That maybe that'd be better if I did it that way first or switch this around or
maybe it needs more of an explanation and maybe it's too verbose.
And so I'll get to,
if you don't do that,
I feel like you're not doing the whole job.
Do you,
do you,
uh,
are there any particular comics?
Do you say comics or Comedians?
Comics.
I don't think it's,
who gives a shit.
I don't care.
I'm just wondering if there's some weird into some guy's website and it said a
comedian is of this,
but a common cause of that.
I'm like,
okay,
yeah,
I'm a comedian,
but I'm also,
I'm a standup comic.
I either wanted to fuck you know what you do,
what are we crazy?
Oh I'm just speaking for myself.
But no,
I mean,
I mean it's a weird thing.
It's a weird thing,
but people are,
people are obsessed with that.
Is there anyone who stands out as having a really consistent process to you?
I guess Louie.
Louie CK.
Louie.
Yeah.
He's very inspiring to me.
It makes me,
um,
it makes me hustle because he's like really obsessed with work.
It's really obsessed with getting things done.
You know,
he,
he does a whole new hour every year,
like religiously.
That's like really cool.
It's,
it's,
it's inspiring,
you know?
And it makes you a,
I'm really,
I've really loved stand up and to this day I'm,
I'm a huge fan of it,
you know?
Even if I never did it again.
Yeah.
Like if I said,
you know what?
Stand ups,
too much work as podcasts is easy.
The UFC is pretty easy.
You know,
these are,
these are much easier gigs and stand up.
I'm just going to quit this shit.
I would still watch it all the time.
I love it.
I love seeing a guy who was really funny,
just unique ideas that I didn't think of.
I love it.
I just,
it's,
it's to me as a fan,
um,
it's my favorite art form to,
to enjoy,
even though I,
that's what I do.
It's still my favorite art form to actually enjoy it.
I would always,
I love when I ended up seeing,
I actually saw Louie when he was working on some material and sag harbor at this
tiny,
it's a bay street theater and the audience and maybe 100 people and that was
awesome to watch to see somebody who's really well known working on their stuff
in a smaller setting.
That was really,
it's fun for me to see people work through the tough stuff,
you know?
Yeah.
Well there's a lot of bits,
like a,
Chris rock had a bit,
um,
that he did for,
he said he did it for like a year.
Louie told me the story actually before it worked and it bombed for a long time.
It was his,
one of his classics.
The,
I love black people,
but I hate niggers right up there.
Right.
That's a call Lassek Chris rock bit.
I mean,
it's one of the best bits I think in the history of comedy.
I mean it's just so,
it's so genius and controversial.
It's got an edge to it.
It's got everything.
It does everything you want and like a great classic bit.
It's every punch lines.
Perfect.
It's just a genius bit.
He said bomb for a long time before he figured out how to do it.
You know,
I had a bit that I did early on in my career about um,
watching tigers fuck on the discovery channel,
but they had a documentary wants and then just show it to you on television and
you don't realize how pathetic you are,
how physically pathetic you are until you watch wild animals.
Fuck.
Because it's like the wild giant Predator fuck.
And the,
the um,
the female tiger,
when it's in heat,
the male can mate.
There was many times it's 50 in a day and so they show these tigers like he'd
been fucking for the 30th time and he bites her deck and he's just,
just her and she's roaring and snapping back at him and swatting him each
fucking the shit out of him.
And it makes you just completely want to quit having sex.
Like,
how can I compete with this?
And that bit was like my,
it was the death of me.
I would try to work it out and I would do it in the middle of my set and they
would just eat shit.
They would just call rash.
It would just bomb,
it would ruin the whole set.
And then I'd have to pull myself out of it.
And it took me forever to figure out how to do it.
I don't know what happened that made me figure out how to do it.
But one day I just got it right and then I couldn't follow it.
So it had to become my closer,
excuse me.
Bless you.
Thank you.
But um,
that was a bit that I couldn't top forever.
And
then when I let it go,
it was like I was losing like my best friend.
The pit was a destroyer.
It was,
it was just couldn't be stopped.
it was the patheticness of man with,
and I became the tiger on stage.
I mean there's,
it's,
you know,
what a good sound system.
You can make some crazy fucking tiger noises with a in a chair.
And I was fucking this shit.
It wasn't like the greatest bit have ever come up with,
it was a distracter.
It was just,
there's,
as far as like a closing bit,
it was like the perfect closing bit.
It took a lot of fucking work.
Took forever and it ain't shit.
For the longest time I couldn't figure out the right way to express it to
people.
I couldn't.
There was a lot of people that didn't want to hear about what,
how you would like to fuck.
Okay.
And you have to open them up to that idea.
It's not like you can't just go on stage and you know that you can,
if the people know you,
but you can't just for the most part go on stage.
And he'd start talking about fucking,
because they're like,
well,
who are you and why am I listening to your sex habits like you,
you have to somehow or another open them up to your unique way of thinking and
they accept you into their mind.
And then you can talk about fucking,
you know,
and that took me a long time to figure out that the people had to accept the
fact that you are going to drive this conversation,
which is what happens when someone does stand up.
You're,
you're,
you're accepting the fact that they're going to take your mind on this journey
of imagination and,
and taking you into places that you didn't expect to go to.
You will laugh because they will take you a long familiar pass,
but then exposed to things that you maybe thought that only you saw and then
take you places where you didn't expect and you're going to laugh hilariously.
But if the guide leads you on a shit path and the path is all clunky and he's
all like,
he's got a lot of iga or he's a,
you don't want to hear him talk or you know,
there's something wrong with the way he's perceiving himself as opposed to where
other people are perceiving them and it's glaringly obvious and what he's saying
then you know,
then nobody wants to hear you talk about fucking dude.
Okay,
we don't want to hear it.
And so that was really my problem.
But part of what my problem was,
I wasn't that good of a comedian yet.
Like I had a good idea,
but I wasn't,
I was clunky.
I would make these above.
It was like a guy who knew how to punch really hard,
but I don't know how to box.
Right.
You know,
it's like you could get in there if it could figure out how to do it,
but you can't always figure out how to do it.
And so it became a craft issue,
became an issue of learning that the what,
what the actual relationship between the performer and the audience is very much
like a massive gnosis.
Yeah,
that's what it's very much like,
I saw a documentary recently that had been recommended to me a million times and
I'd always intended to watch it,
but it was,
for whatever reason,
always put on the back burner.
And I don't know how it's been received in the comedy world,
but the comedian with the track,
Jerry Seinfeld and loved it an up and comer contrast in styles with the most
brilliant aspect of that,
that documentary is that he put that other dude in to make them look bad because
he know the dude,
he knew the dude was a freak.
So it was like,
listen,
I'm gonna I know I'm a little fucked up.
What I'll do is put
some of their more fucked up than me.
And so what was the other cat's name?
I can't remember.
Let's pull it up.
It's Adams.
That's right.
40 items.
So you know,
I thought and they use like a lot of like,
you know,
do she shit.
That may be a young man might say and then they gave it up to,
they stuck a camera.
So He's,
why would,
why did they choose him?
Why did they choose him?
Why didn't they choose like one of the better comics in New York?
Like what,
for what reason?
I don't know.
To make Jerry look better.
That's what they did.
They knew that kid was crazy and they're like,
I know we're going to do here.
We're gonna,
we're gonna,
you know,
we don't want to put Jerry next to Chris Rock.
Don't,
don't like follow Chris around because Chris is process.
Looks like more fun.
Let's get Jerry with someone who's really neurotic and it was really young and
this probably never had a camera in front of them before and let's,
you know,
talk about personal shit with them and ask him about his career.
And you know like especially when you're starting out like you're,
you're the idea of even having a career.
It was such an obsession.
It's like,
God,
I got to make it.
I have to.
And almost anyone who gets through the salmon ladder of standup comedy,
you have to be crazy and obsessed.
Yeah.
I just thought that it was really rude to take someone who's crazy and obsessed
like orange,
which we all are in the beginning and focus the camera on him in direct contrast
to someone who's a multi-multi multimillionaire with a hundred Porsche's who's
trying to go back out to his loving throngs of millions of fans with some new
material.
So it was total one.
Where's the young wacky guys trying to make it and you're sticking a camera in
his face and then the other one,
either you're falling one cherry fucking Seinfeld,
you know,
but that wacky guy makes Jerry Seinfeld look awful good.
I mean it was,
no,
that's completely fair.
I think that it was though still a pretty fascinating discussion of the creative
process.
Even if you're not a comic.
Like for me as a writer,
I loved seeing,
you know Colin Quinn and Chris Rock and Seinfeld and I think Louis was in there,
a bunch of guys just talking about the process,
the fuck ups working on the difficult to material when you know there's a gym
there.
But like you said,
like you have a feature but you don't have a product,
you're like,
fuck,
like if I can make this work but it can't work on its own.
And how you battle that.
And I remember reading,
I read a lot of,
I'm sorry,
I read a lot of books on fiction writing even though I don't write fiction
because fiction writers have to battle more demons than nonfiction writers.
They just get,
they get trapped in their heads more than nonfiction writers.
And I thought there was something to be learned there.
And one of the lessons I took from,
I think it was letters from a fiction writer or letters to a young fiction
writer,
collection of letters from really experienced pros to people who are just
finding their feet.
And one of them was effectively like,
you think you've wasted 10 pages when the first good paragraph comes,
10 pages in,
but it's not a waste because you needed those first 10 of shitty pages of warmup
to get to that one paragraph.
And uh,
I just found it,
I found it really helpful for actually finishing up for our chef.
I watched the comedian because I was,
I was stuck and I was like,
fuck,
you know what?
I'm like thinking more about writing is knocking at fix this neuroses like this
neurosis that I've developed,
so I want to comedy.
Wow,
that's awesome.
Yeah,
really helped.
It's a very unique creative process as well because you're,
you're,
you're giving birth to a bits that are much like life forms.
They have a very finite life.
He didn't take them and you could record them.
They'll go on forever.
But the reality is,
as far as your relationship with them,
it's very finite.
You have a year or two with a bit.
So like there's a bit right now that I'm doing on vegans that I don't want to
let go.
I love it.
So it's like,
it's like one of my favorite creations and,
and,
and it's,
um,
I know it's,
I'm going to put it down the summer on a DVD and then I've got to have to let it
go and it's over.
You start new ones in some fashion appealing to you that it's a femoral,
that it comes and goes.
Is that part of the appeal?
Like why do as long as I have it on,
on DVD or CD so people can enjoy it,
it would suck if,
uh,
there was,
there's a few bits that I have never made it on anything that are just wacky ass
bits that I came up with somewhere and I never figured out how to make them
acceptable and then I just abandoned them somewhere.
Are there any,
uh,
I'm just trying to figure out,
something that fascinates me is looking for the anomalies,
right?
Whether it's in sports,
uh,
you know,
people who are really good,
who shouldn't be or people who succeed despite not doing what they've been told
they have to do.
Like Enya for instance,
I don't listen to Enya.
However,
what fascinates me about her is apparently,
and it could be getting this wrong,
she doesn't tour,
she's does zero her and she makes a gazillion fucking dollars cause she's like,
I don't want it to her.
I'm not going to do it.
I don't care if they tell me that everyone has to do,
I'm not going to.
And so I'm always wondering,
let's say looking at,
you know,
standup comedy writing.
I can think of examples too.
Like I've never done book tours.
I don't do book tours really.
Uh,
just refused to do it in bookstores at least.
And for you.
And it's forced me to figure out more interesting,
innovative ways like partnering with Bit Torrent for the four hour chef or
whatever other people in comedy who really break the mold.
I mean,
I know,
uh,
like Louis did is,
he had his,
I guess it was a new hour of content,
wasn't it?
That he sold directly on his site.
Uh,
but are there,
are there other people who really stand out,
is kind of breaking the mold,
but it's,
Louis really is the most innovative guy today I think.
And because he's,
he seems to be,
to be the,
to meed rather to be the most obsessed with creating stuff,
whether it's his TV show,
which he edits himself,
writes himself,
you know,
I had a conversation with them at the Improv after his first show didn't work
out.
And I said,
if you had to do anything differently,
like what would you do differently?
And said,
I would fire the writers.
He goes to the good guys and everything,
but it just,
it wasn't what I wanted it,
you know,
just so this time what he decided to do was like,
you really,
the only way to get what you're trying to get out is for you to do it.
Yeah.
You have to do it yourself.
You know,
you have to edit it yourself.
You have to write it yourself.
It's just most people don't have the energy or the,
the obsession to do that and do stand up.
You know,
it's really kind of amazing and
not just to stand up,
like,
and rely on an act that you sort of rehashing every,
you know,
every time you go on stage,
you've done the same act for the last six years.
You could always do it.
No,
he's doing a whole new hour every year.
So that's really inspiring.
It's really inspiring.
How do you,
this is just tangentially related,
but how do you,
uh,
how have you made your career decisions?
Like you mentioned,
you,
you asked him if he were to do it over again,
what would he do differently?
Fire the writers.
Like how,
how did you evaluate opportunities and projects and whatnot these days?
I'm very instinctual and that sounds like really cliche,
but I really believe that the right answer is always right there.
I,
there's a few things that I've pondered in the,
in my past and I've gone back and forth like,
ma'am,
hmm,
should I do this?
Should I not do this?
But ultimately the right answer's always right there in front of my face,
even if it's not what I want to hear.
Even if the other answer pays you more money or the right answer is always,
and I've,
I've taken the wrong answer a few times.
Like my did fear phone though,
but,
uh,
it was the right answer financially.
So I sort of accepted it.
But when I'm,
when I look at it like as far as like the,
what I'm going to enjoy,
what I'm going to enjoy when I'm going to really excel at,
it has to be something that,
uh,
I'm,
I'm fascinated with.
It has to be something that I locked into,
whether it's the ultimate fighting championship,
whether it's standup comedy,
whether it's anything.
I do podcasts and whenever anything I do,
I have to be fascinated by it.
Yeah.
Otherwise I'm not going to be successful.
So I just go towards that and that's what I've always done.
It's just somehow or another worked out that cage fighting commentary and
standup comedy sort of can be packaged together.
It doesn't seem like it should be,
but it can be if that's actually what you are really in interested in what I
mean and you know,
whatever else you're interested in that can be packaged in there as well.
You know,
whether it's fitness,
martial arts,
playing pool,
you know like do,
what the fuck is on your head.
That's my,
I heard a rumor that you are very,
very good at pool.
Yeah.
Very good.
I had no idea.
That's pretty good.
Yeah,
I think I could.
I could play professional if I had time.
Why haven't you get took good?
Well I've been obsessed with it ever since I was young.
I tore my ACL in 1990,
I think somewhere around there and I had to have surgery and while I was
rehabbing,
I started playing pool and I had a buddy of mine who was really good and I met
him during that time and I was just fascinated by what he could do with the
balls that I couldn't do.
So,
uh,
I started,
just started playing like every day I'm obsessed with it now.
I have a table at home and I practice,
I play in a tournament every now and then.
I came in second place in a,
in a local tournament really recently.
I should have one too.
I'm just fucking,
I get a little aggressive sometimes because uh,
I may come to their pool,
like pool player maybe don't go together quite as well.
There's certain times where you shouldn't shoot a shot.
Like they'll the like the right,
the correct way to play is you play a geometry and percentages so you play like
geometric angle,
you know,
you leading off the ball.
Like,
I want to go in a very specific angle towards the next
ball so that as I collide with the ball,
that natural progression of the object ball in the cue ball,
I could chart it.
You know,
so I'm looking,
if I hit the ball to the left,
it's going to bounce off to the right like,
and so all that is going on in your head and you're,
you're,
you're calculating it all.
That's like the,
you're not supposed to shoot shots.
We have a 10% chance of making them,
he's supposed to play safe.
But I try to be a hero.
I'm like,
but if it's fun,
if I,
if I cut it in,
I win,
you know,
so I'll take wacky shots and I wound up like losing a tournament because of
that.
But it's fun.
I have a,
I have to sort of manage the idea of winning and the idea with going out cowboy
style because I go out cowboy style a lot when I play pool.
Cause if somebody leaves me a crazy shot,
I'll try to cut it in.
You know,
cause I make them like half the time and that's almost worth it to me.
But in the sense of a race to seven tournament,
it's not worth it at all.
Right.
You know?
So if I played professionally,
if I decided to go do that,
I would have to practice for about six months I think.
And then I would have to play on a lot of tournaments and then just go and do
that all day like they do.
But I think I could do it.
Such a fun,
such a fun game.
Yeah,
it's an awesome game.
I got really into,
I became fascinated with darts recently to him because I saw it on TV in the UK.
I was there recently for the uh,
the UK book launch to the four hour chef and they had darts on TV and this guy
stands right next to the board and just announces the scores like one 2150 and
just announces each,
each round of scores as they go.
But these guys were incredible.
I just could not believe how accurate they were in this,
in this tiny like double or triple boxes.
And they put three right on top of each other.
Yeah.
It must be very satisfying to be that good.
When you hit a bullseye look,
that is fucking satisfying.
The hand eye coordination games are very satisfying,
but to me that's pool.
But pool also has a million other things into it.
As calculations.
Every,
every table looks different.
When you're looking at the DART board,
you're always seeing the same God damn dark.
Right?
That's true.
You know where to throw it.
But when you're playing pool,
you're looking at a million different shots.
Change on scale.
Yeah.
And you have choices to make.
You could go left,
you can go right.
How do you want to get to that other ball?
Do you want to try and take a long shot?
What do you want to do?
And so there's all these decisions we have to meet and you have to execute.
So I have to know what's going on.
And then you also have to have this hand eye coordination and understanding
where the balls go.
It's just we're losing it because of video games,
which are understandably really stimulating.
And really fucking fun.
It takes a long time to get to the point where pool pools really fun and get
really good at it.
As a side note on video games,
so I'm uh,
I'm in the process of funding some,
not,
not wholly on my own,
but funding some studies at UC.
So University of California San Francisco looking at a cognitive performance
training,
uh,
specifically using video games,
iPads and also the connect for physical movement.
And uh,
we're going to be playing around with uh,
transcranial direct stimulation,
which is effectively where you take the equivalent of a nine volt battery and
apply a current across the cranium and they've done testing with a military
shooters,
snipers,
they'll put them into a first person shooter game and they can get them from
like 20 to 100% and in a,
in an in an afternoon.
It's incredible.
And so the next step would be,
which is what I want to do,
but there's a lot more involved once you add the pharmacological aspect.
I want to do a combination of cognitive training without the transcranial
stimulation.
Then with transcranial stimulation and then with things like modafinil and to
see what kind of will come kind of superhuman performance.
You can,
you can manufacturer
where of this Dave Aspery program that he,
he's a part of their,
I believe it's in Vancouver.
He goes and they,
they hook you up to some fucking machine for five days and approved as Iq by 20
points.
I don't,
uh,
you know,
I,
I've,
uh,
he's a smart guy.
I've,
I've heard some of those interviews.
I don't know anything about the location in Vancouver.
You can,
you can also,
uh,
I'd be interested to know how we went about doing it.
Of course,
the,
you can game Iq pretty easily.
For instance,
if you learn something called the,
at the consonant system,
uh,
it goes by a couple of different names where you,
you learn how to associate numbers with consonants and then you turn those
continents into images and you can get to the point where you're memorizing a
hundred numbers and can do it forwards and backwards in maybe a week of
practice.
And then you're able to completely destroy the serial memorization tasks that
they have on Iq,
on Iq tests.
And I know that because I,
I took a multiple high Iq test and did training in between them.
This was probably 2005 direct specifically to see if I could improve what is
supposed to be fixed.
And you,
I mean aspirin knows this of course,
but you can definitely,
you can,
you can absolutely improve your Iq.
So please explain how the hell that works.
Okay.
You,
you connect numbers,
two consonants.
So I'll give you an example.
It's so it's super easy and in fact not to like plug the shit out of it.
But the,
uh,
in this,
in the four hour chef I talk about,
uh,
encoding,
basically taking something,
it's really hard to memorize like numbers and tagging it to something that's
easy to memorize or have to remember like images.
So if you took,
for instance,
the number one,
number one has one downstroke so it's a t or a d.
Okay.
So you can use either letter then,
uh,
that number two is an end cause then has to down strokes.
Number three is an m because it has three down strokes and on and so forth.
Right?
So if you had let's say a one and two and you're trying to remember the number
12,
well one can be t and two is n.
So tin you could just remember like tin can and then all of a sudden you have
one and to remember 10 and then you might have like 10.
And then something else like let's just say three,
one which would be like myth.
So it could be like a tin baseball,
like a baseball Mitt made out of tin.
Okay fine.
They have 10 minutes and then you just go on and on.
You memorize these things.
So let's say we were doing it in this room right now.
You could have,
if you,
I used to memorize serial numbers on,
uh,
on,
bills that I would have in my wallet just for exercise.
Like I wake up in the morning at a time myself to memorize serial numbers and do
the back and forth.
And so I did this in college that I've taken a lot before or after beating off
cause that's what everybody did definitely before.
Okay.
I'm more of an evening lanker just my personal preference,
but this is more of a wind down with my glass of wine.
But the uh,
the,
the way you do it is if you had like 10 minutes,
right?
And you'd,
you'd visualize that in one location in the room and then you could come right
next to like you'd go to the microphone,
then you place the next two images there.
So you have basically four numbers at each location and you can get to the point
literally in a week.
It's very easy where you're memorizing 20 to a hundred numbers at a time and you
can do it bat forwards and backwards.
What I used to do to freak people out,
and this is totally trainable,
totally,
totally coachable,
is I would have somebody pull out a bill out of their wallet and be like a $1
bill,
$5 bill 20 whatever.
And I would memorize it and I'd be like,
all right,
don't spend this and just hold onto it until I see you next time.
And I'd like to circle something like put a circle on it or whatever.
And then I'd see them the next time and I'd be able to remember,
okay,
well when I was with Joe and he pulled that five out of his wallet,
like we memorized it in this room.
So I would recall the room and I'd see you like three weeks later and I'd be
able to tell you exactly what the numbers were on that bill
because the visual memory is so strong.
That's what,
that's what,
uh,
Cicero it used to do for Senate debates.
When you had to memorize content and talking points for like three hours at a
time,
he would,
he would place his topics as images in different locations in the hall where he
was actually speaking.
Is that why your memory improves when you physically write things down?
That's a good question.
I do think that,
at least in my experience,
I don't know what research centers to support this,
but the more senses you involved,
uh,
involve certainly kinesthetically for me it helps tremendously if I write things
down physically.
That's why I do all of my editing by hand.
My writing,
editing,
I'll,
I'll do,
I'll first draft on the computer,
but I always printed out and then edit by hand as I do revisions.
So you edit by hand,
meaning you,
you write notes printed out,
print the notes out and I can just,
I can like the nonlinear connections or I'm like,
oh this paragraphs you have three pages later,
these three paragraphs she get cut that,
that,
that the right on the paper.
Do you both sticky?
I write right on the paper and I just put the connections together.
My ability to edit on a computer where I have to scroll is much less intuitive,
which means the writing ends up less natural.
If I had it on a computer,
that makes sense.
Cause sometimes I have to go over a paragraph or something that I've written and
I'm like,
wow.
It just doesn't seem to flow with the paragraph before.
But it seemed to as I was writing it,
and it's also,
there's less for me,
at least when I'm writing,
there's less psycholo psychological resistance to kind of killing my babies.
The things that I love,
if I can just cross out with a pen,
if I have to delete it on a computer,
I'm like,
ah,
but then what if I need it?
Uh,
that,
that one gem that I think is that twist of phrase that I think is so genius,
but it's fucking out of place.
It doesn't make any sense.
All of that stuff.
Stacks of those that I go to and desperation when I,
whenever I release a new bid or a new DVD or something like that,
I didn't have to go over the notes.
So I'll go into some shit that I just left hanging around.
You could do with those,
I'll tell you.
So there's a guy named Tucker Max,
he might or might not know the name,
but he,
uh,
an author has had a number of New York Times best is a very controversial guy,
but one of the,
he's a brilliant marketer and one of the things he did is he took his stories
that were kind of second rate that he had sitting around.
And he was like,
Eh,
like never put them in a book cause he's like,
I'm not going to charge my readers,
you know,
20 bucks for this then it's not worth it.
And so he put them all into a book called sloppy seconds that he gave away for
free.
But in that book he had samples like his best stories from his other books and
it put all of those books back on the New York Times bestseller list.
Hmm.
Really,
really,
really clever.
That is pretty smart.
Very smart.
Yeah.
I feel like it's a good idea to give people shit for free too.
It's always a good idea.
Well check.
Okay,
I'll give you a crazy number.
So when,
when I did the partnership with bittorrent,
so bit torrents usually associated with pirated content and I,
I approached them,
I was introduced to them,
uh,
and immediately that same day went down to their office in San Francisco,
got together and pitched a promoted landing page for the four hour chef was
like,
I'll give you two and a half gigabytes of free material book stuff,
chapters that were cut,
uh,
you know,
like 24 hours with GSP,
like his hold,
like specked out,
calorie by Calorie Diet.
Like all this stuff I'll give to you for free,
including all this extra stuff.
And then just,
just put up a link that says,
you know,
support,
this artist that clicks through to my Amazon page,
we'll see what happens.
Great.
So they helped put it together,
took next to no time to set it up.
Had a more than 60% click through rate from the download page to Amazon.
That's insane.
Like,
wow.
Six out of 10 people click through to the Amazon page.
It just astonishingly effective.
Astonish and effective.
Yeah.
Some weird situation now where you're like out of bookstores now,
right?
Oh,
it's still going on.
Yeah.
Boycotted by Barnes and noble and all that.
And what happened?
How did that,
I forget how that got started,
right?
What that was it?
Panera bread.
Oh yeah.
I didn't experiment with Panero.
Uh,
and a pilot just to,
uh,
mostly that was to scare the shit out of the publishing industry because Barnes
and noble,
I think they're closing like 500 stores or something.
So,
I mean,
there,
there are their pallet and brass on the titanic at this point,
but,
but they were able to hurt me in the beginning for the lists.
But what I did is I partnered with Panera very briefly for a trial because they
have 1500 locations around the country.
So I went to everybody and in publishing to Poop,
they're pampers and panic.
And uh,
since the book hit the hit the New York Times number four New York Times and hit
all the other lists,
uh,
have been,
have been going through all of these unlikely suspects,
like Kroger's rosaries,
a Williams-Sonoma urban outfitters carries it now.
So I'm just like,
look guys,
you're going to force,
you're going to force other retailers to take your place by pulling this kind of
high jinks.
So what is the hygiene?
So that's what I'm [inaudible] the high jinx is the,
so the four hour chef was the first major book acquired by Amazon publishing.
Not Amazon.
I am self publishing,
but an actual office in New York City competing against the major publishers,
signing authors to giving advances.
It was run by Amazon and Barnes and nobles of course,
extremely threatened by Amazon.
So they're like,
we're not going to care anything that Amazon publishes.
And,
uh,
that is why I'm not carried in any,
any,
uh,
that seems rather douchey.
It's not,
you know,
it's,
it's not terribly effective either.
What they did,
which was smart is,
uh,
from a competitive standpoint.
I mean,
it's not going to save them,
but,
uh,
I have,
I have a bunch of theories about what they're going to do a in a lot of
respects,
but they,
because they blocked the book from the Nook,
right?
Which is their kindle equipment of those fucking things.
Yeah.
So they blocked,
yeah.
So they blocked the four hour chef from the neck.
They won't carry it.
But here's what that does.
It's scares other authors because why should you use the knuck when you could
use the kindle?
Here's what happens is if you're an author and you're like,
which publish three or should I go with,
if you see that Tim Ferriss sold 37,000 digital copies first week,
fourth of the four hour chef,
none of them counted for the New York Times because they were reported from one
source,
I.
E.
The kindle.
If I had sold 20 copies through the Nook,
it would have been number one said they they,
they're playing a game of,
of intimidation tactic,
but it's not going to work.
And even if a,
anyway,
I'm enjoying it because it's just like this David and Goliath battle where I get
to do all this guerrilla warfare,
which I enjoy.
Wow.
It sounds crazy.
Yeah,
it's fun.
What a,
what a bunch of Douche is.
Barnes and noble turned out to be.
That's such a Douche move.
So the book man,
you sell books.
What do you care who the publisher is like what kind of pussy fucking way of
doing businesses that that's,
you know what that's like someone trying to,
that's like crabs in a bucket.
You know the expression for one crab has climbing on top of the bucket.
They never there because the other crabs
grab him and pull him down.
Like what?
Do you know why you upset that Amazon is doing well?
Why don't you realize that people don't like your fucking store so much or fix
that you do do something different.
Draw people in somehow other than having magazine racks,
you know,
what are you going to do,
do,
do something different?
So they did decide to do something different.
They came out with their nook and they have their own books and you can order
them online.
Basically the same thing that Amazon does or does this transitionary period.
But you know,
don't,
don't fucking go after other companies like that.
That's stupid.
Someone,
the stupid thing is,
I had a bunch of my readers who were like,
I went into Barnes and to hold to get it and they said they didn't have it,
so I just order it on Amazon.
I'm like,
yeah,
of course that's what's going to happen.
It makes it more money for Amazon.
You dummies,
except you can't be a constant.
This world,
it's,
it's too late for that.
You can't just do that because they'd all send,
people hear about it like you telling it on this podcast,
which reaches millions of people and they're going to go fuck them.
And so there's a certain number of people right now that are Tim Ferriss fan
fans like,
well,
you know what?
Fuck Barnes and noble,
they can't get my business.
What's the other one?
There's Barnes and noble and there's any of this,
the porters,
but does this already out it out of business gun and had done so no one exists
anymore.
It's just Barnes and noble Barnes.
Well then there are a few in the middle of the country like books,
a million they bought of me too,
but they're all there.
They're all in the final death now.
So everyone's going to be gone like record stores.
It's going to be the same thing.
I think it'll be very similar.
The Amazon will rise.
Phoenix from the ashes.
What,
what,
what will continue to succeed are bookstores that offer one,
a handful of things.
Number one,
books that are actually tactile experiences,
beautiful books that cannot be replicated in digital.
And I think for instance,
I,
the four hour chef I think is the ironic part of the whole thing is actually a
beautiful book.
It's better if physical,
the digital,
but uh,
I think,
uh,
like fade on their number of publishers that create really beautiful books and
they will continue to do well.
The second is for instances,
bookstore in San Francisco called omnivore books.
It's only cookbooks.
And you walk in there and that person is the Obi wan Kenobi of cookbooks.
They will be like,
tell me five things you're interested in.
I will pick the perfect cookbook from the last 200 years for you.
And you're like,
oh,
208 years.
Oh,
they've everything.
Like half of their books are out of print.
It's fucking awesome.
Wow.
It's Omnivore.
It's Rad.
There's another one.
Uh,
let me get this right.
Slotnick cookbooks,
Slo,
t nic,
Ken,
New York City,
same story like this.
The woman only thinks,
eats,
breathes,
believes cookbooks.
She knows everything there is to know.
So you go there,
it's like the Mecca of cookbooks.
I saw there's a,
there's one on Anthony Bourdain's show he went to in New York.
I always had to be her.
It was,
it had to be as fascinating.
He goes to them the,
apparently there's a few all throughout the world.
He goes to them,
you know,
whenever he's on the road,
he goes to different cookbooks stores and buys these,
yeah.
Ancient cookbooks.
Really fascinating.
So fun cause they have these,
these fantastic ones that are like the gentleman league,
I've to cookery or whatever.
Like these like quaint but awesomely accurate stereotype typical books or you
read it and you're like that's still accurate.
All like 1930 or whatever.
It's great.
There's so fantastic.
I wish we could have recorded those freaks and see what they sounded like when
they were just walking around and talking like a reality show.
I went to go live in the thirties you know,
I mean wouldn't be interesting cause if they,
if they look back at the future and judge us by real housewives of Miami,
Oh God,
fuck.
I would like to know what these people were really like.
You know,
it has to be,
I mean they weren't the movies,
they weren't logged gable,
you know,
they weren't that.
So what,
what were they like?
Yeah.
Well I wish I could see a documentary on people that live back then I met,
I met this military dude the other day,
Joe,
that he said that his friend is really high up in the navy or something like
that.
You know,
you shouldn't even be telling me this.
And his friends starting to go crazy or something and he wants to talk,
he wants to come on this podcast because he says that he has like he's really
high up and he has seen these chairs that the military uses that you sit down
and,
and it kind of like goes into the future and uh,
they could then use that to see,
uh,
how to like react and wars.
Like they see wars in the future and then they build stuff to fight these wars
in the future or something.
Who taught you to a retard buddy to a good dude who's just really dumb and make
shit up and he fucked with your head and then who you are repeating it online
and he's like,
you got a strong
incepted I made a boo you Brian Rear bench.
We'll fucking stupid.
He actually talked about on the podcast but I,
but actually just to try to tag that to something that we mentioned just before
we,
we went live the,
we were talking about the hate this label.
I can't think of a better way to explain it to like the psychic imprint of
events.
We were talking about this.
So let's see what we were talking about.
We're talking about the possibility that the Rupert Sheldrake,
I think it was the guy who came up with this idea that everything has a memory
and that very specific intense events in a certain area can leave some sort of a
psychic imprint.
Correct.
So that's the,
that's the theory right now.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm naturally a skeptic.
I think people should be skeptical.
But one of the reasons I went to a,
and if I've told this before,
stop me,
but I've,
I've had wait,
wait too much bulletproof and coconut waters stop.
Now.
A part of the reason I went to Princeton Undergrad is because they had this
place called the scientists,
the scientific anomalies laboratory.
It was run by a guy named professor John,
and they had a lot of the top statisticians and mathematicians working on
investigating unexplained phenomena,
including very specifically things they could test in a lab,
like telekinesis,
moving objects with your mind,
etc. Uh,
and,
uh,
different types of clairvoyants,
which they called remote viewing.
So the,
the anecdote that I now went to their lab,
I looked at their testing equipment,
who was awesome.
Like they had this huge,
you know what a Pachinko machine is.
It's like a verb vertical pinball machine in Japan and it shoots balls up and
they,
they bounced down on these pegs and you try to get them into these slots and you
can make,
you can win money.
It's hugely popular game.
They had an enormous version of this.
It was about 10 or 15 feet tall with hundreds of these pegs that were there were
meticulously evenly spaced and it was divided down the middle.
Uh,
and these balls would shoot at the top and subjects would have to consciously
direct the ball to one side or the other.
And then they would look at the statistical probability of a split one way or
the other.
Uh,
uh,
they did a lot of really fascinating stuff,
but it was,
it was well funded at one point by some of the defense industry.
So the remote viewing,
this is the,
this is where I'm coming to the psychic imprint part.
The way this works is,
uh,
they would have a number of envelopes and a transmitter.
This is the person who would then take one of the envelopes along with a number
of the experimenters,
open it up after they'd left the room and it would have gps coordinates,
they would travel to a specific location and his job was to transmit to the
receiver.
So you would look at,
look at the scene and transmit that visual scene to the receiver who's a
separate person sitting in a room,
pad of paper,
a voice recorder,
pen,
et Cetera.
And uh,
it's when they,
and by,
when you say transmit,
let's explain to people what remote viewing.
Yes.
A means no phone.
There's no phone,
there's nothing.
Basically,
like if I were looking at you right now and I trying to send an image of
everything that I see to someone like a hundred miles away for them to write,
sketch it down on a piece of paper and the,
it has some pretty potentially amazing applications to intelligence gathering,
military,
whatever.
So what the,
when Professor John,
I landed at uh,
I guess 1995,
96 at Princeton and they were just,
uh,
I think a year later shutting down the scientific anomalies laboratory because
the cold war,
it was over like there wasn't enough funding,
whatever.
And he's like,
all right,
I'm going to give you like the final wrap up presentation with some of the data
that we've seen just to blow your mind.
And he's like,
I don't expect people to change how anybody thinks about this because there's a
lot of stigma associated with some of these phenomena.
But let me tell you what some of the things we've seen and told the story of
using four or five of the same locations for remote,
you don't have to say travel out.
And it was always the same like gas station or whatever.
And at one point they had this collection of drawings from receivers who had
proven themselves to be pretty adept at this stuff that uh,
all looked the same for this one gas station,
but it wasn't a gas station.
And what they found out later when they did background research on the location
is that the,
the receivers had been drawing barracks that existed at the exact location of
the gas station like a hundred years before in that crazy.
Why?
So in other words,
images that they had drawn all the same
and they were all of these barracks
correct.
The data existed at the exact same location that now had a gas station that this
guy had been transmitting.
So it called into question sort of some really fascinating it sort of time
continuum questions.
Right.
So it's like,
if you can see the past in the same sense,
like,
and then we're getting into all sorts of wacky physics and Stephen Hawking
stuff.
But I just found that really fascinating.
This is this something they made?
This was in a presentation.
They made a presentation that's available
98 this was in [inaudible] 90.
Uh,
people can look it up.
I'm not sure if they'd be able to find a recording.
I would love,
I mean,
I'd love to watch it again if I could.
It was j a h n Professor John.
You see,
what are the images for corrected people?
Drew,
how similar hand sketched similar enough that you could tell they were drawing
the same thing.
I mean it wasn't,
we're not talking about uh,
take photograph fidelity because these people weren't trained artists,
scientists.
Uh,
but ah,
yeah,
there's some wacky stuff out there.
There's some really
that's the wackiest it's pretty intense.
Yeah.
That seems like just the fact that they drew what can be reasonably interpreted
as the same image.
Yeah,
pretty cool.
Pretty Weird.
Yeah.
I don't discount ghosts fully.
I mean,
people have said like,
you know,
like one of those guys from those ghost hunter shows.
I absolutely,
he was like,
you know,
I heard you're a skeptic.
Yeah.
That,
yes.
But discounting the idea of something,
some image,
some imprint of a moment that's stuck in the same geographic area that make
blink in and out of existence.
I don't,
I mean,
I explained talking,
explain,
making noises and the other person that has images in their mind that coincide
with those noises and you agree,
even though everybody's voice sounds differently,
we all agree on like a,
a similar hard soft combination of that represent actual all that fucking nuts.
The Internet's nuts.
Everything's nuts.
Ghosts aren't any crazier than TV.
TV's pretty fucking crazy.
You know,
the fact that you can broadcast and they figure this shit out a long ass time
ago.
At the same time everyone in the country can watch the same image that's going
through the space.
Yeah.
That's pretty fucking weird.
You know,
the,
the ghosts aren't any weirder than that.
It's a lot less weird.
There are local,
they there in that one area,
they don't travel around and you know,
it's,
yeah,
I mean,
I don't,
uh,
I think you hit the nail on a wall that's just me being like conclusive where I
shouldn't be.
But I think that the point you made that's really important is that it might not
be an entity of any type.
Right.
It may not have any,
it may not be a sentient being.
Like the ghost isn't like,
Oh,
I'm hungry,
I need to go,
blah,
blah.
No,
but if there's a traumatic or intense event that leaves some type of residual
trace that you can pick up.
I give you an example.
I went to San Diego to Ted Med,
this is many,
many years ago.
I went to one of the earlier tedmeds,
which Ted for medical innovation and conversation.
Great,
great event.
But we stayed at the,
uh,
core Natto hotel or core Natto in,
in,
uh,
San Diego.
And I stayed there.
I was there the first night and I was really fucking cold.
It was warm out and I was freezing in my room and I was just like,
I couldn't sleep.
It was super,
super cold.
Next morning guide delivers breakfast and he goes,
oh,
uh,
how'd you sleep?
Do you see any ghosts?
I was like,
what?
Excuse me?
And he goes,
oh,
no.
It's always really famous for ghosts because this woman hung herself in the room
next to yours.
You didn't notice that there,
the door was painted over.
And I'm just like,
fuck,
you know,
it didn't make it any easier to sleep after that.
The Deloitte was painted over.
What do you mean they didn't use the room?
Cause the woman hung herself in it.
So they painted,
they painted over the creases in the door so it couldn't be oh,
uh,
open.
Uh,
they sealed the door paint.
That's what it looked like.
Yeah.
And it was painted over.
I not only they locked it and then painted it over because people wouldn't drink
old school paint,
I guess.
Doors used to get stuck when you painted them.
And uh,
but I knew nothing of that when I stayed there the night before and I was like
freezing cold and could not sleep at all.
And it was hot out.
It was just a weird experience.
And then only found out after the fact.
It's like,
oh yeah,
somebody commits suicide.
Dead Lady laying on top of you,
like dry humping you while you're trying to,
could have been.
Yeah,
it could've been.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't discount the idea of ghosts because to me it's not any crazier than sons
or any crazier than black holes or hyper of us.
All that stuff's way nuttier than a ghost,
you know?
You know what I mean?
Like the things that we actually do exist.
It's just the real problem is so many people are full of shit.
That's the real problem.
The real problem with any of the data when it comes to any paranormal and
anything weird and French is that so many people have shitty thinking.
They have massive confirmation bias and they're dumb and they tell lies.
They'll just make up stories about being abducted by aliens and you know,
listening to him like,
man,
I don't know.
And you know,
I was one friend's like,
dude,
this guy fucking worked for the government man.
Like this guy.
He knows.
And I'm like,
man,
he might not know.
Like,
look,
he seems like he's full of shit to me.
You know?
It's like God dammit.
There's no way that you can tell me though that everybody,
every single person that's experienced some sort of a supernatural phenomenon is
crazy.
Are full of Shit.
I think it's just a matter of like sifting through massive amounts of data and
getting to these like,
okay,
what is that a diamond?
Look at that.
That's a diamond.
Put that there cliff.
Okay,
let's look at all this stuff.
Oh,
it says,
what's this right here?
Look at that.
Put that over there.
Click when you're just going to have a fucking river of bullshit though,
they're going to have to dig your hand in and pull out the diamonds because most
of it's going to be crap.
That's the real problem with ghost stories.
A real problem with everything.
I mean it's,
there's so much bullshit along with potentially credible data that it just all
gets thrown out.
You know,
we,
we are in a weird time as,
as an organism and I think that's ineffective.
It's very effective to communicate with words,
but it's also very ineffective cause people can lie.
And that isn't,
I think that's a temporary thing.
I don't think that's gonna be around much longer.
And I think once that's not around anymore,
once you can really understand what this person's saying immediately when
they're saying it,
it's not going to be as simple as being able to lie.
It's going to be,
I'll,
I'll know what you're thinking when you're saying something.
Well,
we'll have a much deeper insight into each other.
Then all this ghost stuff becomes really interesting because then if you tell me
a ghost story,
I know it's fucking real.
If you tell me you saw a Sasquatch,
I know you fucking saw Sasquatch and I know there's a God damn big foot out
there.
I know that an alien ship landed in your,
I know,
but right now,
I don't know.
Right now I've got this clunky thing called language and a lot of people abuse
it and they don't,
they don't tell the fucking truth or they're crazy.
That too.
You know,
they might tell the truth,
but their truth,
it's fucking Mickey Mouse is flying,
you know,
a harp and it's a,
he's boom,
boom,
doom over your house with the harp.
Like,
yeah,
it's real.
Like to hook them up to a lie detector could probably tell you it actually
happened.
I wonder if people would be able to get to the deep conversations to that
stabbing each other first though,
if they were totally honest.
You know what I mean?
Like there's going to be a transitionary period like the rat,
I don't know if you've ever heard of this,
uh,
this movement called radical honesty.
Have you ever seen this guy?
Sorry,
where are you supposed to be?
100% honest about everything you're feeling and thinking in the moment.
And so a friend of mine named h Jay Jacobs,
he's a really funny writer.
He wrote a book called the Year of Living Biblically,
where he tried to follow every rule in the old and New Testament for an entire
year.
It's a,
it's an amazing book,
including stoning adulterers because he was like,
fuck,
I need to stone adulterers.
But I don't want to kill somebody.
They don't specify the size of the stone.
So he had like a pocket,
like he wore a white robe,
huge beard pocket full of these little pebbles.
And he walked around central park asking people if they were adulterers and they
need stone them with these pebbles and run away.
But
yeah,
it looks like he's looking to get his ass kicked.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
He,
he's,
he throw a rocket.
Somebody you can find the wrong dude.
Just got fired.
His wife just got a nail or whatever,
go to jail.
He throw a little rocket and you,
I beat the fuck out of you.
So one of the other experiments,
that agent,
not a big guy,
one of the experiments that hey did was radical honesty for I think a month.
And it was called,
I think you're fat.
Oh,
that was the title.
That was the title of the article for Esquire.
And so he,
so he'd be talking to his wife and she'd be like,
blah,
blah blah,
don't you think?
And He'd be like,
I'm sorry,
I'm really bored.
And I stopped listening five minutes ago.
Oh yeah.
Has not radical honesty.
That's being a douchebag part.
Yeah,
you do think those things.
But the reality is part of being a nice person is when you love somebody,
you let them talk and you actually listened to them.
Yeah.
And when you don't do
that,
it's kind of a country thank deal.
Cause you could listen to them and then you know,
you decide whether or not you actually have anything in common.
But some people they shut that shit off a long time ago.
Right.
And I talk at you when I'm done,
you talk at me,
but no one's really talking to each other because I'm not listening to what the
fuck you're saying.
That's like one of the most common traits.
Relationships.
It's one of those common traits among humans.
Man,
I have a really tough time and there some really cool people down here,
but I have a lot of trouble with la man.
You should I,
San Francisco is superior.
Well I think everybody in San Francisco has Asperger's.
So they just say what's on their mind,
whether it's appropriate or not.
So,
which is is really refreshing but can be frustrating.
But the converse in la,
man,
it's like Jesus,
like how many layers to this onion of a person have to peel back to know what
the fuck you're actually trying to say to me.
Yes,
that is a huge issue.
And it's an issue because of the entertainment industry.
The entertainment industry fosters bullshit because you have to pretend to be
something a unique and different and meanwhile you're just another fucking
person who's going to pretend to be a killer and a movie or pretend to be a
princess or pretend to be at.
You're pretending you're faking it.
So like you to be the best at it,
you have to be fake.
You have to be a big fake person's good at line.
It's really bananas.
And not only that,
you start to embody this look,
look,
here's the perfect example.
Sean Penn is a brilliant actor.
He's very good at that.
Most likely,
cause Sean Penn,
it's fucking crazy.
Okay.
And Chris Rock was hosting the Academy Awards once and he was making fun of Jude
law about how Jude law's and everything.
Whenever we got,
Damn.
Can I see move without Jude law?
It was pretty funny.
It was just joking.
It's a subject because Jude law is very prolific and he's excellent.
So He's used it a lot of movies.
So fucking Sean Penn takes the microphone afterwards and says,
Jude loves you know these movies because he's an amazing actor.
And I'm like,
okay,
I want to beat you to death.
I want to beat you to death for,
for getting literal about a fucking Chris rock joke about a prolific actor.
Jesus Christ.
You fucking pretentious cock sucker.
Did you really say that?
Did you have friends at all?
Do you have anybody that bust your balls?
Do you know?
They take themselves so God damn seriously.
And there were donkeys plus award show wherever where saw a monkey suit.
You were,
oh,
we're all gonna agree to wear the same stupid outfit that we never were for
being comfortable in real.
Yeah.
Why don't you put a bow tie on?
You can't put me there with a white shirt and oh,
buttoned up jacket.
Are you guys rich?
Can you dress any way the fuck you want?
Why is everybody dressing the same?
Oh,
were elegant this evening.
Why we have traditional attire on,
I just want to say that Jude Law's an amazing actor.
Yes.
Here,
here.
Let's go back to being pretentious to Chris rock actually exposed some reality.
Did he make fun of something?
No,
we have no room for that here.
We're helping the world,
but providing the arts.
You fucking Twat.
I want to punch you right in your stupid face.
He plays like tough guys and movies.
We'd like,
this movie is pretty good.
It plays a Mickey Cohen and this,
uh,
this new gangster squad moment,
fun movie.
It looks like Horse Shit.
Sean Penn's very good at that,
but most likely he's good at that because he's fucking crazy.
Which is why you had to explain a joke during the Academy Awards when a fucking
brilliant world renounced standup comedian as the host the war.
Holy Shit to do a comedian make a joke.
Oh No,
stop.
Let me explain which with a great team you're making here.
But I think in the same academy awards it was when Chris Rock was talking to
about 50 cent and said this guy's had dealt with everything.
He took more gunshots to the face than Jenna Jamison and they were both in the
audience.
Nobody got up and defended Jen Jamison.
I was very offended.
You're allowed.
You're allowed to say that.
Yeah,
you're allowed to say that.
But that's a free target to make fun of Jude Law because he's a brilliant
doctor.
So she butchered laws in a lot of films cause he's a brilliant doctor.
I just wanted to say,
I just want her to straighten everybody out.
I wanted to exercise my ego about some shit that happened earlier that I thought
was unjust.
Are you making fun of June law during our special day when we were a monkey
suits,
you know,
fuck choke.
You like this one hand.
Are you going to,
Oh,
you'd do the scent of a woman like ranger choke.
I wouldn't even use my elbow.
I wouldn't even have to just grab them like rocky,
like a little rat hold on tight
shut.
It just,
I pretentiousness is really intolerable and it shouldn't be tolerated in your
friends and it shouldn't be tolerated in celebrities either.
That's nonsense.
That kind of stuff is nonsense.
You're talking about acting cunt face.
Okay?
You're not saving the world.
You're not time traveling.
You didn't invent a nuclear weapon.
Okay?
You know how you develop faster and intern and either and it's not like you came
up with five g,
you pretended to be a gangster and a movie and you were good at it.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Rick did attain the main distracting me for an hour and a half cause that's all
the fuck you did.
Okay.
You,
you made me sit down and I enjoyed your performance and it made me not think
about my life and I got some thrills out of it.
It was very exciting and enjoyable to follow along.
That's it.
That's all you did.
Okay.
He didn't fucking change the world.
You're not awesome.
You're guys get it.
Pretending fuck heads drives me nuts.
It drives me nuts.
And that is the one thing that I hate about this town and you know,
and being a person who lives in two very real worlds,
the world of fighting in the world of standup comedy,
being a cage fighting commentator,
I see the realist of the real shit.
Human character exposed,
people cracking under pressure.
People rise to the occasion.
I see the realist of the real shit.
And then comedy,
nobody laughs,
you're not funny.
Okay.
If your point doesn't work,
they don't accept it into their mind.
It has to really work and you have to be in that moment.
You can't think about something that's completely opposite and say something
funny and have it be funny cause it won't work.
There's something weird going on.
It's not just the words coming out of your mouth,
it's you about those words as they come out of your mouth and people recognizing
that you're in the moment,
which makes it funny.
Those are two very real things.
So when I see someone like pretentious and someone just someone who's like
taking themselves way too fucking seriously or wants a lot of accolades and
respect to something that's basically just,
that's what you're,
that's what you do,
man.
You're really good at that.
This guy's really good at fixing people's eyes.
This guy's really good at driving cars.
You don't be an asshole.
It's really simple.
Don't take yourself too fucking seriously because you don't deserve any extra
appreciation.
You don't deserve any extra respect.
You don't deserve any extra attention.
You deserve exactly what the fuck you've already gotten,
and you should be super duper thankful for that.
And anytime you want more than what you're getting,
you're a cunt.
It's that simple.
If you demand respect,
you're a,
you're a cunt.
You're simply a cunt.
It's your problem.
You're,
you're imbalanced.
You need to take a yoga class.
You need to go on a mushroom trip,
go to Perot,
take some Iowasca,
do something,
but stop.
It's 2000 and fucking 13 we have no time for you anymore.
I have no time this time.
There's so many.
It's rats,
rats in a fucking sewer.
Goddammit.
What,
uh,
when do you think,
but also cool people?
Oh,
don't get me wrong.
Yeah.
There's one,
there's populations,
massive.
I mean,
Joey Diaz,
so Ari should fear that my friends that I met,
I met all here.
So it's not all kinds.
There's some awesome people here.
When do you think there's
time?
Anytime soon when the content creators,
whether that's the comics,
uh,
documentarians,
whatever it might be,
aren't,
are going to be able to create what they want to create outside of the big
agencies and whatnot.
I mean,
is,
is that
okay
infrastructure really necessary?
How much longer is that going to be necessary when people and brands start
coming to the podcast?
When brands start coming to the bloggers,
the writers directly,
so they have funding of some type,
like,
yeah,
what's,
what's to,
what are the,
what is the benefit of operating within like the big,
big agencies,
the managers do this,
that and the other thing to produce,
let's say 30 minute,
30 minute TV show right now.
Well,
I think the real benefit is going to be with people who are excellent at what
they do.
Instead of it being some sort of a,
instead of it being where the situation where it was before the Internet was,
they controlled all of the entertainment.
It was essential that you be with a studio to get a television show on.
Cause that's,
you can't make your own network.
You can just put your own network on.
Like when Fox came along it was shocking.
Like there's a new network,
what is this?
And they had a good show married with children.
Holy Shit.
And the Simpsons,
what the fuck is going on?
We have a new play.
Or in this game it was one new player in the Goddamn history of television,
ABC,
CBS,
NBC,
which was going on forever.
They,
it was a dictatorship.
they owned the output.
Now everything is on the Internet.
So in sense when it comes
to low budget things,
when it comes to your,
uh,
ability to transmit like a sitcom sort of a thing,
especially like a single camera one,
God,
you can do that with your iPhone.
I mean,
we can make a single camera sitcom with no audience for the God damn iPhone.
And it would be as long as it would cost our time,
but we'd have to write the scripts out.
But what's lighting do you really need?
I know what you look like if the point they can't,
if it's funny,
I'm gonna Laugh.
It's really
hilarious.
Even need to do that.
You know,
how much really do you need to spend to make something good?
Well,
it just means to be good.
Yeah.
Um,
but when it comes to like the hobbit where you're still gonna need,
right.
A team of bad motherfuckers who've been doing this forever when it comes to,
especially I think when it comes to special effects and creative effects and
things like that,
like Cgi,
like the guys who make like,
you know,
alien,
like there's a,
the guy who is making the,
I forgot his name,
I really apologize.
He made me a bust of a aliens vs Predator.
Like one of the aliens and a,
I'm going to,
I'm going to bring it in here.
It's fucking sick.
It's amazing,
isn't it sick?
Yeah,
it looks awesome.
It's so dope.
Yeah.
I love that shit.
And um,
uh,
Pat Mcgee is making a,
a,
a giant American Werewolf.
He's a making a full size American Werewolf in the studio.
It's so sick.
It's got yak hair covering.
Have you,
I'll show it to you.
You're going to shit your pants.
It's the most beautiful thing ever.
Especially it's very fucking movie.
Fuck.
Yeah.
It was a scary movie.
It was an amazing movie.
But I read that's never going to go out of style.
You're going to need those guys.
You're going to need special effects people.
And like a guy like Albert Chino or,
I mean,
I just use him.
I should use a,
okay.
A guy like,
um,
uh,
Leonardo Dicaprio.
Yeah.
The,
the performance that he put in in that Django movie.
He's a bad motherfucker.
All right.
You need that guy.
You got to find,
you know,
you need guys like that.
There's,
there's certain people that obviously they're,
they're super skilled at that,
that art form,
you know,
that was,
that was also a lot of people.
Uh,
I've become fascinated by Quentin Tarantino.
I don't know that guy at all,
but I've been really fascinated by his also creative process.
I've been on this kind of trip with the creative process stuff recently.
You want to get really fascinated listening to him talk on different radio
stations.
He's a completely different human being.
There's something going on with that guy.
He's,
he just like a chameleon chameleon or he's crazy.
There's something up when he's talking to black people,
he talks about,
he's so funny.
It's awesome.
I called Brian up there,
I call you up.
I left her a text message.
Whatever you tweeted it or yeah,
cause I was listening to it in the car and I was like,
when I texted you,
I think like do hilarious.
It's the most preposterous thing you've ever seen in your life.
Here's just American Werewolf.
Whoa,
look at that.
Isn't that the sickest thing I've ever done?
Awesome.
That's super cool.
Um,
but he,
uh,
so he's talking to Howard Stern.
He sounds like a gay guy.
He's like,
he's,
he's being a feminist to Alpha,
to the alpha of Stern.
And then when he goes on to the Anthony Show,
then he's one of the guys.
He's more,
he's louder,
he's more heterosexual.
Then when he's
on the Jamie Foxx show,
Jamie Foxx and him start talking.
He goes full black.
He's talking about Laurence Fishburne.
He's like,
fish,
got his fish guide,
his fish got paid.
The motherfucker got his,
like literally says the motherfucker got his,
like he's completely black.
Wow.
It's fascinating.
And then,
you know what someone said to me when I tweeted that,
um,
they go,
how does,
how does a black,
how does a person's sound black?
I knew that was kind to be,
and I'm like,
how the fuck do you think it does?
We playing games here?
Are you telling me that if someone saw talk like this on TV,
you wouldn't say,
why are you talking black?
Yeah.
I'm not saying that every black person talks like that,
but to pretend that some black people don't talk like that,
it's crazy.
But there's that fucking little racism button that everybody loves their finger
on.
Oh,
you bet.
Something racist.
Oh,
press this little button.
I'm very sensitive.
What did you mean by talking black?
Oh Gee,
what the fuck do you think I meant?
Why are you responding?
You hoping I'm racist?
What do you,
are you looking,
are you searching for something?
The idea that you're pretending that there's not a very distinct vernacular to
the African American community negates the whole idea of ebonics,
which is actually discussed about,
they were teaching you bond next to people to try to get educators to understand
what the fuck black people were saying.
Okay.
You don't need to know any more than that.
What does ebonics?
It's ebony.
Okay.
It's black,
goddammit ebonics.
What's the beginning?
The beginning of it is black.
It's black talk
and apparently,
well I guess
he's got a black belt in ebonics.
He went right in.
And do you have any audio of it?
I thought we could probably play it.
I mean,
we're a serious look and this is not making fun of Quentin Tarantino.
I think it's a part of his genius.
I mean it absolutely is making fun of Quentin Tarantino Gamete.
Don't get me wrong,
but I love him.
I think he's fucking awesome.
He's my favorite director by far.
If you had to look at like the movies that I really enjoyed over the past few
years,
whether it's killed bill or pulp fiction or I really loved to Django and or
Jango whatever.
And uh,
I,
uh,
I loved 'em inglorious bastards to these movies are fun.
They're there,
they're wild or great experiences,
but him as a person,
part of being I think a genius in anything.
And I definitely think he's a genius.
As you gotta be a weird,
you gotta be,
you gotta be all over the last year a little off.
And I think a guy who's so creative when it comes to like dialogue,
when a guy who's like so creative about personalities and his films and how he
sets them up,
I think,
you know,
he's like constantly like being all these different people,
he's like,
I think you would have to be to get dialogue that believable.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
You almost have to be able to shape shift.
And maybe just can't turn it off.
Maybe just never thought about turning it on.
It's just how it is.
But the one I was going to make when you brought up the Leonardo Dicaprio,
I was going to say that the entire piece in that movie on phrenology,
so the bumps on the skull and everything else,
Leonardo Dicaprio brought that into the script.
I was his idea.
Uh,
and so I was,
I just got me,
got me to thinking about
anyway,
the,
the writing process and how I admire the fact,
cause I could see how I would get very protective of my fiefdom if I were a
writer of say a script fiefdom.
Yeah.
If Ife correct.
Never used that word.
I don't even know what it means.
What does that mean?
If you're a fief Lord,
you have a,
in I guess what the Middle Ages,
you'd have fiefdom and you'd have the serfs and then you'd have the clerics have
the fucking high priests and then you'd have the Lord of the manor or the king
or whatever.
And so that would be a little,
when people say a fiefdom,
it's like a territory that they defend typically if you're using it like a
corporate environment.
Right.
So this person has their fucking silo and they're like,
Hey Jack,
I know you want it.
You mean well,
but like we don't want your input here cause I want to protect my job by not
letting you fuck with this portion of the company that I control or whatever.
So,
but I could see getting as a writer,
I'm very meticulous and I,
I do not like people fucking with my writing and less and less,
they're better at writing than I am.
Like as some of my friends like Neil Strauss,
right.
Incredible writer.
I'll have him,
I will gladly let him tell me what you,
what of my stuff sucks.
But uh,
the fact that like Tarantino actively engages his actors in altering the script,
I just think is,
is pretty cool,
eh,
with the results that you guys,
yeah,
there's not a lot of people that do that.
And that was the style of a Paul Simms who was the producer of news radio for a
second.
I was in,
it was really fascinating.
Like,
uh,
Dave Foley essentially like rewrote like half of that show.
Like in the process of rehearsal.
Some people are willing to do that,
but you know,
the most important thing is getting it out there the best way possible.
And some people recognize that the best way to do that is to allow for some
fuckery or some,
I shouldn't say fuckery manipulation,
some,
some flexibility allowed fuckery.
I've never heard that.
He's really bullshit though.
So it's not bullshit.
It's the wrong word.
You never heard fuckery?
I've never,
no dude.
There's some,
one of the best things to say if you,
you know,
not really sure if this is legit is I believe perhaps some fuckery is a foot
fucking some fuckery in the fiefdom.
I started talking,
I started using the word fuckery to describe a fake martial arts.
That's where first I first entered into my way of speaking.
Cause there's a lot of always just strikes.
It's the word.
There's the word is correct when it comes to like shit martial arts because it
is fuckery.
It's just like cultish stuff.
It's like they're pretending to have magic powers.
You know,
it's,
fuckery is the right word for that.
But there's some,
you know,
there's some really wacky videos out there.
If you were seeing like kind of two experts who just touch people and they go
flying across the room is some of them.
There was this black dude who,
uh,
had these students,
it was really amazing.
Um,
I became completely obsessed with Black Kung Fu guys for awhile because there
was a lot of them that were like really into like the mystical aspect of,
and black guys are the only ones who are
allowed to use the word,
the arts,
that expression.
You know,
I studied the arts for a long time,
you know,
deep involved in the arts.
But this one dude,
he had a whole,
a school full of people that believed that he had super powers.
And so he would do his class and we'd go up to him,
just throw his hand in front of them and they would go flying and he would do
this to people and they would come at him like they would charge for,
like they were going to attack and he would just go,
Ooh.
And they would flip and fall to the ground.
And flop like fish.
It was hilarious.
It was the craziest thing ever because these people willingly went with his
direction and they did it in a,
they knew the camera was there and they said,
you know what,
I'm just going to play along.
And they all agreed that this guy has power.
So when that guy goes,
ah,
they're pretending they're playing and the guy would fall and flop around on the
ground.
And there's a very famous video of one guy who was one of these guys.
It was a Chinese gentleman who someone convinced him to have an MMA fight.
So he had these demonstrations do,
doing when these guys ran at him,
pull that up because that's more and more interesting than anything.
Pull that up.
And what we'll find this,
um,
Chinese Kung Fu guy gets ass kicked by MMA guy.
That's probably the,
this guy beat the fucking shit out of this poor old dude.
This poor old guy really thought that he could do that.
And he had these students need the demonstration before,
but they would run out of him and he would do that to the top of their head.
They would fall to the ground and conscious.
I mean,
it was really wild to watch.
Hilarious.
And this guy went and he was probably in his fifties or sixties minivan and he
went in as a Kung Fu master and this guy just beat him down,
just kicked his legs,
punched him in the face,
elbow them,
just crushed him,
took him down,
smashed him.
It was just horrific to watch because you're watching not just a guy get beat
up,
which is always,
I don't like mismatches,
you know,
it drives me crazy when I see someone who shouldn't be there,
who's there because someone lied to them about their proficiency level.
So that aspect of it I do not like at all.
But it's fascinating to watch a guy's illusions get shattered in the most
realistic way possible.
He actually had some belief,
no,
this is a different one.
This is another Kung Fu one though.
But that's a dude.
I forget his name.
He's,
he was a fucking huge guy.
Who's an MMA.
That's it.
That's the one right there.
Key I master versus MMA or no,
this is a horrific scene,
man.
This is really fucked up.
Go full screen up on this bitch.
Look at this guy.
So you look,
this is him with his students where they come at him.
Watch what he does.
Look at this.
Look at that.
They just fall to the ground.
This is,
this is insane.
He's like throwing hands in front of their face and they willingly follow the
ground.
They're all wearing black belts to and look,
he wagers $5,000 apparently that he,
he'd look at this,
he's doing these things with his hands and they're like flipping around.
This is real,
man.
This is not like a play someone's putting on.
I mean,
look at this.
He's like throwing his hands.
In the end,
the guys whipping himself back and forth like it's like for whatever reason,
we'll look at that.
That's a pancreas jacket.
That guys where,
yes.
Hi.
Back in the day,
I used to watch Wayne Shamrock as they called them back then.
Ken Wayne.
Shamrock.
I saw the very first,
very first Pancras fight.
He's going to fight this guy who,
uh,
he's wearing a like a,
judogi on this top and the waste is a,
he's gets just got fight shorts on and he's going to beat the fuck out of this
old man and this guy is old.
It's hard to see because it's this low resolution.
I've seen a higher resolution video of it and it's uh,
it's crazy that someone talked this old man
and to believe that he can actually fight.
He has a red masters belt on and this Black Kung Fu outfit and um,
see this old crazy man.
You think maybe like maybe he's losing his mind.
I don't know man.
I mean I think some of them they get so just bought into the illusion.
Yeah.
They get so much love from their students and their students are so obedient
that they really start believing in their masters.
I think it's,
it becomes sort of a self fulfilling illusion.
Nervous.
Well everybody's nervous before a fight.
You can't avoid that.
Your body is going to know you're about to go to war.
But I think with this little white beard,
he actually believes he can fight and the other guy shakes his hand and bows and
now the beating will commence.
They explain what's legal and what's not legal.
The guy says yes,
they bow to each other,
they stand back and they're going to start the time and this whole,
the guy's going to get the fuck beat out of him.
Wow.
And he really believes that he's going to be able to do this stuff and it's
fascinating watching them try to like throw his hands through the air and use
this cheat.
This
throws his hands up in the air and the guy like measure them,
you know,
like a,
like a fucking mountain line about to eat a deer.
He was posturing.
So you just leg kicked him,
punched him in the face.
Now the guy's holding his face.
It was a,
all right dude.
He's like,
I'm okay.
Bruce Lee movies just holding his mouth right here.
Yeah.
He's like,
come on.
Are we fighting?
What's going on?
He's like,
keeps checking his mouth.
Like,
oh my God,
someone hit me.
How is this possible?
So,
so they said,
come on fight again,
dude.
Can't just hold your mouth.
So now the guy realizes this old man's done to,
he's going to just start beating the fuck out of him and the guys still trying
to do Kung Fu and now he's just hammering him with punches,
holes,
jacket,
head kick,
boom.
And that's it.
That's it.
Stop.
Stop,
please.
So the old man actually really
thought that he was going to be able to do this crazy kung fu stuff.
That was his attack.
That's the power.
The power of the mind is so incredible.
I mean like when you,
I don't if you've ever seen a real hypnosis demonstrations,
like the physiological effects that you can produce from hypnosis where you can
take like a popsicle and put it on someone's skin and tell them that it's hot
red poker and a blisters will just erupt on the scale.
Yeah.
Really?
Is there though the amazing,
Randy looked into this and accepted that as this million dollar challenge,
but it seems like something that would be evidence of some weird force of the
mind.
Oh,
they're,
they're incredible thing.
I mean,
I'll give you,
this is something I've never,
I don't think I've ever talked about this a,
not that it's a big,
big discovery or anything,
but when I was in Japan,
this is a lesser example of this,
but,
uh,
I was training,
this is long time ago,
when I was 15,
16 and I was in the judo club.
I was recruited to be in the judo clubs.
That was like my introduction to submission was judo and uh,
had the wrestling background and what not.
But I,
I,
I got my ass did just handed to me and my first tournament because I was like
the big fish in the little pond.
And then I had this killer just eat and like seven seconds destroyed me.
So I started training after my normal practice at Tokai University,
which has an insane judo program.
They're like the Iowa Hawkeyes of,
of the judo world along with a couple of other schools.
And uh,
it's an incredible school.
But at one point they had this really high ranking old judo competitor come in
to do a demo,
like a class.
And one of the instructors was there to be,
uh,
okay,
like to get thrown around and we were working on a foot sweep specifically and
uh,
the old guy was like,
all right,
it's going to look kind of like this.
And he's like,
this is what the motion looks like.
Like you lead the guy to the right like shuffle,
shuffle,
sweep.
And he's like,
okay,
so this is what it looks like.
Shovel shovel it.
But he wasn't doing the throat,
he was just like showing the movement and he went to show the steps and the,
the instructor who was going to get thrown,
like preemptively thought the guy was gonna sweep and then just went up
completely horizontal.
Like he'd been leg swept and fell.
And the older guys like,
what the fuck are you doing?
I'm like,
I'm going to throw you to get,
he said,
get back up.
You know,
only fallen,
I actually throw you,
but the,
the physics involved of like making yourself go horizontal from a fake leg
sweep.
Like,
if that guy,
if I paid that guy thousand dollars to recreate what he did,
he wouldn't have been able to do it.
It was just like the craziest
phantom leg sweep fall I've ever seen.
But he couldn't have done like if you asked him to re replicate it wouldn't have
been.
So he just,
first of all,
he was proficient in the martial arts to know what the correct,
what would happen to his buddies and he was so enamored with this guy that he
wanted to be ultra cooperative.
Yeah.
He was nervous.
You're nervous help the throw along.
Yeah,
exactly.
Cause like the old judo guys are fucking cantankerous.
They're like just angry old guys and they just did you know Jean labelle's known
for like demonstrating moves on people and hurting him.
Choke out Steven Seagal on a Saturday.
I just a rumor.
Yes.
Yeah.
No it's not a robot at all.
I heard it directly from his mouth.
The way he tells it was really funny to give some background.
I go choke them unconscious [inaudible] he just got tired,
tired of decided to take a nap.
Just pants.
Cause Labelle,
I mean,
labella had it easy.
Yes.
Some chops with like Aau judo,
but he stomach for decades,
right?
Yeah.
And he also,
um,
he,
I think,
I forget the guy's name,
I'm gonna say Milo savage,
but he had a,
uh,
like an MMA type fight with a boxer,
you know,
it was a judo versus boxing fight.
And I think he made the guy where it Geeky,
smart move,
I think so.
I can't remember.
But he'd beat the shit out of the guy and just sort of held him down,
flipped him on his back.
I mean,
once he got ahold of you,
he was bear strong and he was,
you know,
legit black belt in judo,
national competitor.
He was,
he was very,
very legit.
He taught a lot of people.
My,
one of my first,
uh,
instructors is this Guy Silvio Preventa,
who was a black belt,
who is a Brazilian guy who was actually a black belt in a gene in the Bell,
Huh?
Yeah.
So gene,
he like,
he knew a lot of a judo finishing holes and they also like knew a lot of the old
catch wrestling pro wrestling holds as well.
There was a lot,
there's a lot of like old school submission techniques and a lot of people had
forgotten the Chine labelle sorta like re reestablished to gnarly stuff.
I mean like finger locks and all sorts of like weird ass toll Holton Shit.
Just like small digit manipulation like Aha could develop the whole book for
police officers on how to choke people at the clubs,
how to use the club,
you know to control somebody because you got a club around someone's neck and
you have like Jujitsu logic,
you know judo logic,
leverage and technique.
Like you could really fuck somebody up at the club now and he shows you how to
choke people unconscious and break arms and retain and detain them.
You know like you know,
you get a guy across the neck and get an under hook on one side and crank that
thing in front of his face and grabbed them.
I was like,
get an over hook on the other side.
Hold on to the,
you know,
you forget that fucking club that in front of your neck now.
Yeah.
You're going to move around freely developed like a whole style based on choking
people with clubs.
You have an opinion and the opinion of a c lot or uh,
like knife fighting from the Philippines and Indonesia.
I know like Dan Inosanto style stuff.
Well,
I'm sure there's gotta be a technique to doing it.
It was just like,
there's a technique to sword fighting and Kendo and there's a technique to,
I just don't know what's the best technique.
It's like when it comes to fighting.
Okay.
For the longest time people thought that like wing Chung was the shit,
you know,
because that was what they had in their area and that's what they practice.
It's like you need to get all the standup styles together in order to figure out
what's really effective,
what techniques really work.
And that's,
you know,
essentially what we're doing and the ultimate fighting championship.
I don't believe that people are doing that with knife fighting.
I might be wrong.
I might,
I could,
I could stand corrected,
but I don't think it's been done to the extent that,
you know,
the,
the way of analyzing it,
the way MMA has been.
You're wrong.
Oh No,
definitely not.
So like when you say like see lot,
I'd have to say,
well how many other people are knife fighting,
you know,
is there a school?
Yeah,
I have no idea.
I mean I just might be traveling to Indonesia in the next few months.
So it was like,
ah,
like you might learn something while you're out there,
check it out in between.
By stab you
see lot,
I'd really prefer not to get,
sounds like a bad
afternoon with a rubber knife that would suck hard rubber knives that she could
easily break a rib or something like that.
Rubber knife.
I won't be jabbed with a hard plastic knife.
Forget it.
Yeah.
Some author wants to come over here and learn how to do some life.
That's actually,
well,
you know,
it's funny because that's been a,
it's like I've had some weird fucking,
uh,
like this Chinese Kung Fu master guy,
not him specifically,
but I've had folks come up and want to like demonstrate like didn't mock and
show me dim mocket speaking events or whatever.
Fill in the blank like mystical technique,
karate chop your neck in mock explaining to people don't,
well Tim Maag,
I mean if you seen like,
you know,
blood sports death touch,
right?
Yeah.
With uh,
actually as Da,
what is it?
The characters in Chinese,
me in,
uh,
in uh,
in,
in a sense press artery,
but it's death that spoons supposedly death touch where people can be like John
and hit you on three pressure points doing like that.
But you can like,
you might die two weeks later because I kind of the north star of the North Star
and with Moose jaw strike,
uh,
it was just like,
what is fist of the North Star?
What does that is a Japanese comic book about that pressure points where like
even had some ones that he pushed and hooked on.
Okay.
Yeah,
that was good stuff,
but I'm not sure where I was going with that.
I know I need more.
I need more coffee.
Uh
hmm
Democ.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Did people want to explain it to?
Oh yeah.
I want to show you if like weird is one like come up and like,
Hey,
let me show you this.
Like Houdini style punched me in the stomach thing.
I'm like,
no dude,
I just did like a 30 minute tech presentation.
Why the fuck would I leave?
Like punch me in the kidney.
It is true.
You do.
You have deceased my master,
right?
Yeah.
Something along those lines.
You've disgraced him with your,
your bad intentions did mock is true.
It is my life.
I am a Kung Fu man.
I might see them on Youtube.
Yeah.
Well there's a lot of people that that want to believe all kinds of not is this,
it is going to do some shit.
Here we go.
Fishing or story.
So he was about to karate chop them there and then he let them let 'em off.
Now he's running out of them.
Pulls that guy.
Oh,
you knew it was coming and he hit him with the elbow.
Yeah,
that sounds like Kung Fu.
That was why I think it's so appealing to uh,
to urban folks.
Like what they really liked about Kung Fu was the theater of it.
Like the,
the idea that you could have like magic,
like there was so it's so cool.
It was like a flare to it.
Like Ninjas in the 80s you remember like,
yes man.
It just saying and so I bought all the Ninja books,
all the how to Ninja two books back in the day.
And every single person demoing anything had a mullet yes in every Ninja book
and they were all crazy.
I remember there was one guy,
and I remember they would ask like martial artists,
like what their diet was.
I thought I would read all those match martial arts magazines and he would eat
all Japanese stuff.
Me.
So soup and you know,
and all these different stuff that he would eat in the morning,
a traditional Japanese breakfast.
Like he was like totally completely into it.
Walking around there with is who has two towed or the tubby tubby tubby shoes
on,
throwing fucking shitty karate kicks.
Have you ever heard of the marathon monks?
Have you heard of these guys know these are legit,
these are there.
Uh,
it's a specific as order of monks and their meditation is long distance running,
like ultra endurance running.
So they'll wear these wovens sandals and they'll run.
They were willing of one or more marathons a day and uh,
they subsist on next to nothing.
I mean it's just these,
the feats of endurance are astonishing.
So their,
their practice rather than sitting for eight hours,
it was run for eight hours.
Pretty cool.
Uh,
I always felt like,
um,
martial arts were a form of moving meditation.
Oh,
for sure.
I think,
you know,
hard cardio can be as well.
Right.
I think that anything that,
that brings your attention to the present tense,
for me at least as meditation,
I mean like when I go to the gym,
people are like,
oh,
like who did you,
who do you train with them?
Like I treat myself,
man,
if I'm doing lifting,
that is my meditative time.
That is when I'm like focusing on cadence numbers,
reps,
whatever,
and nothing else.
Just creating a vacuum,
like a negative space so I can actually recover from the overstimulation from
the rest of the day.
Yeah.
It's a,
isn't it a fascinating thing about the human mind is that that that is sort of
like a thing that you need to do in order to sort of reset things to the
managing the way the mind works.
Managing and kind of like the diagramming it and understanding it and trying to,
it's,
there's so many weird aspects of it that are like,
oh,
okay,
well you need to shut off.
Yeah.
Oh,
you need those.
Sit in a room and think about your life and just stare at a wall and then that
it actually makes you work better.
Sit there and just concentrate on only breathing while I'm not doing anything.
No,
no.
Concentrate on only breathing and the brain would work better.
Like it needs a break.
Yeah.
Like let the rpms subside and it'll,
it'll be good.
And then it'll kind of give you a better assessment of where you're at without
any influence of stress or hormonal or weird,
you know,
sort of pressure of your environment,
all that stuff.
You can sort of shut off a little bit.
And when you do that,
the mind works better.
How do you decompress or sort of clean the slate when you,
when you're overstimulated or feeling overwhelmed by too many projects,
too many balls,
too many emails,
whatever it might be.
Aside from the flotation tank,
is there anything in particular that you use?
Any rituals or anything like that?
The tank is the big one.
Yeah.
So I have it.
So why would I do anything else and what's the best method is not,
there's no better method in my opinion.
There's never been in an environment like it created.
It's to not capitalize on it.
Like people that don't use sensory deprivation tanks that could use sensory
deprivation tanks are crazy.
Yeah.
Like why would you not have access to something that gives you complete total
silence?
Complete the,
if you're a thinker,
if you're someone who makes a living in some sort of creative form,
creating things that the opportunity to have some time alone with your thoughts
like that is so unique.
There's no other time where your body is just off,
just shuts off.
You don't feel your feet touching the ground.
You'll feel your ass touching a seat.
You don't feel a damn thing.
Yeah.
It's a loan with your mind and because of that,
it's like every other method.
To me,
it's like,
you know when someone says,
well,
I don't need to isolation tank.
I meditate.
Meditating on a tank,
it's better.
Yeah,
It's the best environment.
Like sitting there,
cross legged is not as good as being in a fucking sensory deprivation tank
that's heated up with water.
That's the same temperature as the surface of your skin and there's a thousand
pounds of salt in it and you're floating and it's completely silent.
No,
you're,
that's better.
That's the best way.
You know?
That's like saying,
I don't need a car.
I can walk you walk stupid,
but it'll take way longer and it won't be as fun.
And you,
you don't even have a stereo.
What if you're,
when you're traveling,
what do you do or is it just you make do until they get back to until I get
back.
But uh,
if I'm particularly stressed I'll just put it in a hard workout.
It usually goes away in little porn hub at the end.
Yeah.
Little that'll how that helps.
But the,
the hard workouts,
the most important thing,
the porno by itself just as fucking doesn't really let you go to sleep and then
you wake up in the morning for more feverish.
The uh,
the body needs to work,
man eats and eats it.
It stores energy in case something happens.
So if you're the type of person like me who your entire life has been doing like
strenuous activity,
the body has really adapted to doing strenuous activity on regular basis.
Yeah.
So if I don't,
if I take a few days off of any strenuous activity,
it's like,
come on,
what are we doing?
I got a lot of fucking excess shit here.
Like,
I've been making all this stuff.
Um,
you know,
I'm ready to go at a moment's notice.
We're going to lift,
some weights are going to throw some people around.
What are we doing?
We're not doing anything.
So then it starts getting really aggressive,
like a dog that you don't take out for walks.
So,
you know,
have you ever had a dog and grew up with two big dogs?
You don't take it for walks and then you know,
they get fucking crazy and they don't,
they don't know how to relax.
But if you take the dog out,
you throw the ball,
then the dogs were relaxed.
It was a calm dogs like you could re,
it's really obvious and you can learn from dogs and you think that just because
you have a mind that you're not subject to the same sort of stimuli,
the same sort of input that your body's giving you that a dog is,
of course you are,
you're,
your body wants to run around to and you're not doing it.
So it's going to go crazy.
And you think,
well,
I'm a gentleman and the gentleman can can contain himself and I can just keep
myself in check and I'll come home and my kids won't even bother me and I won't
want to hit the fucking parrot with a shoe who bought a damn pat and you want to
kill that fucking thing.
Why?
Because you're imbalanced because your body is storing all this extra killed
juice and there's a fucking squawking burden your living room.
But meanwhile,
have you just got back from a marathon and you probably talked to that bird.
What's up buddy?
Everything cool with that map?
You wouldn't even hate him.
You know,
he'd be like,
he's fine.
It's just a bird.
Because I was processing,
it was like a cola and I was just processing.
But the,
I was trying to explain a very hard to,
hard to rationalize concept or hard to,
uh,
hard to appreciate concept for a person that doesn't have that kind of a body or
a person who doesn't have that kind of a lifestyle or that kind of a way of
thinking and everybody has their own sort of activity and energy level.
But for some of these like a very go,
go,
go person,
it's very important that you have regular outlets.
Like you can't just accept the fact that you can turn it on and turn it off.
Like,
no,
it's,
you have made,
have sort of a commitment to have this sort of a body.
So this is the type of body you have.
Like there's a famous story about cyclists,
um,
that a friend of mine told me where I'm in a situation rather about cyclists
where when they're on EPO they have to exercise.
Like in,
oftentimes they were touring and it'd be on this bus Stang and he would hear in
the middle of the night one of the guys getting out of bed and pulling his bike
out and and running,
you know,
and dry riding his bike.
And the reason why he did it was even though they were all supposed to be
sleeping,
he had EPO in his system and he absolutely had to exercise like his body was
producing and the exorbitant amount of red blood cells because this drug and
that made him a like vulnerable,
like his heart was,
you know,
feeling kind of funny.
Like he's like Jesus Christ,
I've got to get,
I have too much blood.
You've got to got to go out there and blow off some steam.
And I think that is,
you know,
much like there's no free rides in terms of mental performance.
When I look at something where,
okay,
well what,
what,
what do you need when you're on a drug that's an enhancing thing.
You need to blow it off.
You need to actually exercise.
Well,
I bet you actually probably need to exercise anyway for optimum performance.
You know,
there's like your,
your body has to work in order to get better at working and when you,
you work it all the time and then you shut it off for a little while.
It's like,
come on,
we gotta,
you know,
you have a commitment fuck head.
You can't take a week off working out,
goddammit.
You know,
and then you was just to get super stressed.
I remember going to Alaska on the,
on the Rinella trip for the,
for the Caribou experience and doing manual labor every day pretty much.
I mean,
just walking around,
stalking,
carrying stuff,
whatever it might be in the cold,
all that.
You got the worst of that.
Uh,
and having no fatigue during the day whatsoever and immediately falling asleep.
Yeah.
That was the same exact experience I had.
Same exact Karen's credible,
no fatigue during the day whatsoever.
No need for naps,
constant sweating,
constantly running out of breath,
climbing up to the top of hills,
but yet wide awake,
up dinner and
they'll eat dinner,
the beat dark out.
All right,
we'll see you guys at six,
boom out.
Such a wonderful feeling.
I mean,
I came back after whatever it was,
maybe five or six days without any calendar,
any iPhone,
any laptop,
any screen,
and he,
any watch,
anything like that,
no inputs,
basically very few unnatural inputs rather.
And it felt like I'd taken six months off is really the reset button.
Reset buttons.
Amazing.
Tell me more about this 32nd sprint thing that you were going on about.
Oh yeah.
Uh,
I think,
uh,
Gibala G I B A L A,
I'm believe who's done a lot of the research,
and I want to say this is probably getting this wrong,
but something like mcallister,
that's a,
that's a street in San Francisco,
uh,
and,
but he's based in Canada.
I,
he's looking at repeated bouts of a maximal exertion,
let's say 32nd sprints on a cycle.
And how a total of say three to four minutes of sprints could,
uh,
had comparable adaptations in the body for,
from an endurance standpoint,
not just sprinting standpoint,
uh,
as a steady state endurance for five to six hours a week.
Yeah,
it's really fascinating stuff.
He's done a number of followup studies that have since confirmed the findings
and now people are also duplicating this study so it's not a one off.
And uh,
so does that mean that someone could try these sprints and do something like,
you know,
these four minutes of just a hundred percent effort for 30 seconds off for
whatever and back and forth for four minutes and they would be able to run a
marathon?
Uh,
I don't know if,
if that in and of itself would be enough,
although I have talked a lot about the transfer from a strength training,
specifically deadlifts is this fascinating to endurance running,
which you'd never put together necessarily if you were looking at what the,
what the,
the adaptations are supposed to be from two very different types of training,
but it's to end Brian Mackenzie,
he's these down here somewhere,
uh,
who's written a book about this and using the four hour body as well,
but,
uh,
using predominantly resistance training,
deadlifts,
and nothing longer than 400 meter repeats.
Typically one or 200 meter repeats to train in eight weeks for a marathon,
like eight to 12 weeks.
You're ready for like a 50 miler.
And I've had readers do that.
It's insane.
I've had readers literally,
I've never run a five k and then do like a mountainous 50 k after training for
eight to 12 weeks using,
uh,
not having run anything longer than say a handful of miles.
Wow.
So when you get to something like ultra endurance training or triathlons and
something like that,
then there's a certain amount of conditioning that's unavoidable as far as just
the constant pounding on the pavement.
The way your,
your joint adapts to the fact that you're here,
you're doing something like that.
Like that's not that you don't get that sort of result,
but you get the,
the cardiovascular benefit is actually,
I think the opposite.
So it's,
so you're developing the strength tendon,
ligament strength as well as the,
uh,
what is it that they call it the ground reactive force from,
let's say sumo deadlifts,
sumo deadlifts are the fastest way to improve sprint speed,
by the way.
A sumo deadlifts or,
or you can do conventional,
but what does that mean?
Sumo deadlifts is just a wide stance deadlift and you'd actually be pulling the
bar.
This trainer down here,
he didn't,
you should,
you should be.
This guy's amazing.
Barry Ross and he's trained,
uh,
he trained Allyson Felix who's incredible superstrong track and field world now
Brooke,
all sorts of world's records and his entire training program is based on the
dead lift Max,
like two to three rep Max deadlift.
So in other words,
he would have them come in do,
and this is,
he's modified it slightly,
but let's just say to keep it simple,
a three sets of two to three reps with four to five minutes of rest in between
sets with plyometrics after each set.
So you'd do pulling like a two rep max from the ground only to your knees.
Okay,
so it's not full range of motion only to your knees.
And then you drop the bar that's devoid hamstring issues.
And then you do plyometrics for like,
you could do five jumps or you do like 10 meter sprints and then you start the
clock,
four to five minutes recovery.
He did the same thing again,
four to five minutes recovery,
same thing again.
And following that protocol,
uh,
which,
I think I called it effortless superhuman with my usual kind of hyperbole,
but he,
uh,
I put,
fuck,
what was it?
It was like 120 pounds on my Max deadlift and something like eight weeks.
It was insane.
Insane.
Insane,
insane,
insane.
That's include not believe in what the coolest part about it from the standpoint
of say,
endurance or fighting.
Oh my fucking God.
Like from the standpoint of anything where you're looking for pound for pound
power,
I put on less than 10 pounds,
probably closer to like five pounds of muscles and nothing.
I mean,
that corresponded to that magnitude.
Strengths.
That's insane.
Nuts.
Totally,
totally insane.
How long did it last?
It sticks around.
I mean the,
now this is something we,
uh,
you know,
you and I have chatted up before,
but like the persistence of effect,
it actually sticks around a lot longer than size in my experience because the
size is so dependent on your eating.
Uh,
the,
the eating habits of free is one of the arguments against performance enhancing
drugs is that not only does a person who is used performance enhancing drugs
have a benefit when they using them.
They have a benefit when they're not using all of their bodies change.
The by does change.
So there's some really cool stuff and you know,
not making like a legal or moralistic judgment about it,
but with,
let's say you're using,
you know,
decker Darabowin like Nandrolone and growth hormone and all this stuff and you
put together a nice cocktail,
their results in let's just say 20 pounds of lean muscle gain.
Then,
uh,
well there's,
I might get the slightly off,
I'm sure we will correct me in the comments,
but there's some people that are,
that have argued that you,
you create a proliferation proliferation of what are called satellite cells.
And when you then go off cycle,
let's say you lose those 20 pounds,
you still retain the ability to grow muscle faster or have a higher rate of
hypertrophy because these satellite cells can then,
uh,
effectively form new muscle fiber.
And I like the muscle fibers are really cool.
Like the nuclei is really long.
I mean like in some cases like it's actually this big and uh,
what that means is muscle memory.
What people have always thought of as muscle memory.
It does exist.
I mean the physiological basis as I have last seen it at least relates to the
satellite cell concept.
So let's say you can,
you're taking IGF one are,
I mean that's getting pretty fancy,
but all of this stuff and you do have a persistent benefit.
You may lose that mass for a period of time,
but you can regain it in a much shorter period of time.
Uh,
when it comes to strength,
I found that to be very persistent.
So in the case of let's say the dead lift or even kettlebell swings like I love,
I love to,
and a Kettlebell swing is like my go to.
If I can only do one thing and I don't have a lot of time,
it's going to be two had kettlebell swing.
Yeah,
I agree.
And I find that as long as I keep my musculature,
like the,
the support,
uh,
the muscles that keep me from breaking form intact,
I can regain strength,
uh,
get up to mind,
sort of former PR,
my personal record and strength in 48 weeks.
I mean it doesn't take a lot of time assuming I haven't lost a ton of muscle
mass.
Um,
but man,
you have to try this deadlift stuff.
It's really amazing.
It's a very interesting thing.
The muscle memory concept,
the fact that once someone has been large and strong,
they can get large and strong fairly quickly.
It's like the body remembers what it was like.
We were talking about mental performance.
Like if,
if someone does use visual consistently and that for instance,
facilitates some type of,
of neural patterning,
uh,
it sort of edges the groove.
So effectively for certain types of recall or for getting less reasoning,
thinking more or let's just say for,
uh,
for,
let's just say for,
I mean I would not use provisional consistently for six months,
but let's just say I did for six months and in those six months I studied in new
language.
So you pay Arabic fine,
like Levantine Arabic,
whatever or Bahasa Indonesian super regular.
So I should be able to get good at that pretty quickly or anybody should,
so I said an Indonesian for six months on provigil if I stop provisionals,
I mean I forget all my Indonesian now f of course not.
I don't think so.
It's a good point.
So it's like you can lock in your gains and perhaps your little slower on
recall.
All I'm thinking about right now is provisional and Jujitsu and what a massive
combination that would be.
Yeah.
I mean,
um,
what was the benefit that the,
there's the sprinter received traumat faster reaction time,
faster,
uh,
take off speed,
basically.
Real.
And I mean,
that's why,
you know,
way back in the day when I was in the supplement world and fussing around mostly
with Acetylcholine,
uh,
the objective was to optimize the neural system,
right.
So that you can have,
have more,
more effective,
more powerful muscular contraction,
but also that you could react,
your reaction speed would be be improved and you can use all sorts of things for
that.
I think.
Yeah,
we did this ages ago.
This has some good stuff in it.
Uh,
with Alpha brain.
Yeah.
Alpha brain.
I find that my,
the other one,
not that I think alpha brain has been posting and some other goodies you go.
Yeah.
Uh,
but what I found out recently is the shit that I was tweaking around with an
experiment thing with in 99,
2000.
Even prior to that,
when I was doing it myself and like my own sort of chemistry lab in my dorm
room,
which I don't recommend
the university frowns upon,
that,
uh,
is supposedly what,
some of the top Jamaican sprinters are toying with right now.
And that's Acetylcholine estrace and inhibition using things like galantamine or
huperzine a,
uh,
to increase the,
basically inhibit the breakdown of Acetylcholine for muscular contraction.
And so like the,
the,
the brute force hypertrophy approach to performance enhancement is one route,
but men,
they're getting clever with all sorts of stuff like fucking interleukin therapy.
It's crazy.
Crazy stuff.
What does Interleukin Therapy,
oh man,
God,
it's been so long since I just heard I can,
I mention names,
but you can probably guess interleukin.
Can we look up a definition for like interleukin six and because I'll,
yeah.
L E U K I n,
uh,
or just interleukin six.
Yeah.
Oh,
Bacopa that's what I was messing around with.
Proinflammatory yeah.
So looking at how you can tool around with,
uh,
inflammation,
how you can tool around with,
uh,
different types of,
let's say even if you're doing injury repair,
like bone morphogenic proteins,
there's some wacky,
wacky,
wacky shit that um,
some of the MMA fighters,
uh,
I don't want to mention anybody by name but have gone to let's say China for
experimental therapies that they're using.
Spinning.
Uh,
not the guy.
You're thinking which one?
Not over him.
No I didn't.
I wasn't thinking.
Oh,
okay.
I'm going to men,
men in days past.
Oh well yes,
these are older guys.
Um,
very big guys who put on like 40 additional pounds of mass in like two,
three months.
And these are guys who are already bigger as your heart deeper than they should
be
hot.
Not very well I think number one.
But number two,
your heart's growing too if you're using a bunch of non selective growth agents.
Do you know what I mean?
That's why like you go to the Mr Olympia,
you're like,
wow,
these are a bunch of like 300 pound muscular men who look like they're nine
months pregnant.
Why?
Because they're fucking intestines are as big around as a boa constrictor.
Oh my God.
Isn't that gross?
I never even thought of that.
That's right.
You know what I'm talking about though?
Huge like pregnant belly.
You're like,
well what's going on here?
Oh maybe I'm what it is.
Their organs grow visceral growth.
That's real.
Yeah.
And here's just just for the kids at home who were like,
ah,
maybe I'll go order 15 first and make it some reason.
I thought that was just muscle.
Like they had like giant ab muscles called giant everything muscles.
They have giant everything.
Oregon's too.
So the how much they have to take to make your organs grow like that.
You know,
I think it's a very personal thing.
And,
and at the highest level athletics,
quite frankly,
you have people who are very similarly mutants genetically speaking at the
highest level,
at the highest level.
I really like in cycling you have people with 25 beats per minute resting heart
rate.
I mean that's not normal.
And at that point I really believe that number one,
everyone's doping.
Number two,
what?
Which differentiates the top performers from like third,
fourth,
fifth place.
Oftentimes it's their drug tolerance.
Like what can their liver clear,
how effectively.
Wow.
And uh,
so for a lot of these bodybuilders,
they're just effectively immune,
not immune to,
but they suffer the side effects of certain drugs less than others.
And uh,
in terms of amount,
I mean she is,
some of these guys are doing like,
I feel like so many more I use of growth hormone in a day than any longevity
clinic would prescribe for a person like an 70 year old for a week.
And they're doing it on a daily basis.
Probably two x the recommended weekly though.
So what would that be like?
I'm just trying to think.
I mean 10 units a day,
at least.
At least 10.
At least 10 hours a day.
And they're combining that.
Keep in mind with,
uh,
things like insulin and whatnot.
Not necessarily at the same time,
be very dangerous to take.
Insulin is very danger.
Insulin is like the heroine of performance enhancers,
you know what I mean?
It's like you can,
like,
you can try,
there are plenty of recreational drugs that won't fucking kill you.
Do you know what I mean?
And then it's like,
oh,
maybe I'll try heroin.
It's like,
no,
no.
That idea for a whole host of reasons,
not the least of which is like,
if I can kill you right off the bat,
if you,
if you fuck up your math or just don't know the concentration and whatever the
with,
it's the same store.
If you,
if you're like,
oh,
I'm going to use long acting and you fuck up and you get fast acting injectable
insulin and then you use the wrong number of use.
Oh,
diabetic coma,
good night,
like you're done.
And it's the benefit of using it.
Uh,
it's a storage hormone.
So what that means is,
uh,
some power lifters,
for instance,
I know a lot of amazing power lifters and guys who were gay and guys gyms where
you walk in and the,
the kind of average is 700 800 pound squat,
right?
Right.
Those kinds of gyms.
A bill,
Bill inject insulin postworkout and then eat a big bowl of pasta.
This,
that,
the other thing,
and it will,
that's Glucose Glucagen glucose into the muscles.
Is that what the it'll,
it'll help.
Yeah.
I mean,
in effect it's going to also increase protein synthesis.
I'm on a,
among other things,
so a big dose of carbohydrates after a workout and increases protein synthesis
as well.
When you're the,
if you're taking insulin,
the insulin,
I've never even met anybody who takes insulin.
Bodybuilders and power lifters,
that's all I got.
Athletes like I'm a mathletes are fighting
MMA guys would be doing it.
It wouldn't surprise me.
Do you think someone could benefit if they did that before a fight?
Oh fuck.
I would never do that.
I mean,
I,
I think that is really asking for trouble.
I know guys who've done EPO.
Oh,
for sure.
For sure.
Yeah.
I mean,
I've tested positive.
Oh,
sure.
A lot of the guys use EPO also don't realize if you're using an androgen,
so to stare when people say steroids are really talking about Anabolic
androgenic steroids,
right?
Ais is if you dare,
a lot of these compounds produce massive increases in,
in a red blood cell production.
So it's like you can get significant,
extremely pronounced endurance benefits from using drugs that are associated
primarily with size.
Really?
Oh yeah.
Which ones?
Uh,
God,
you know,
all of them.
I mean,
my understanding is that most a s are going to produce an increase in red blood
cell production and uh,
I'm blanking
the recovery so mean that's,
that makes sense.
Because apparently all the cyclists were all taking testosterone as well.
Oh yeah.
They weren't just taking EPO.
They were,
they were also taking tests hops from him,
even though they were a little skinny guys.
They were still taking testosterone for the endurance benefit.
Ah.
Also recovery benefits recovery.
Like,
man,
you're getting multiple,
multiple stages on the treadmill.
It's something that a doctor wrote or he said that the Tour de France is so bad
on your body that it,
you could conceivably argue that it's healthier to do with drugs.
Hmm.
You said,
you can see,
it would be argued that if you're taking human growth hormone and testosterone
EPO,
it'd probably be safer on your body because your body could at least recover
from the brutal beating that you're giving it by making it work so hard.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I mean I wouldn't dismiss that out of it.
It seems,
it seems like a reasonable argument.
My,
I mean my,
my fantasy solution to all this,
the doping outrage,
which is just kind of,
it's amusing to me because it's existed since the first Olympiad and well before
that,
I mean people were taking mushrooms and fucking be eating bull testicles and all
that.
Yeah,
I mean it's,
it's been around
wine,
the Tour de France,
the list of things they used to tay,
he used to take strychnine of,
I don't know.
I mean it might not even work.
It's just like there were just like,
fuck it,
let's cheat zoo.
Let's try it once.
Try Rat poison.
What?
I would love to see my dick off it.
What I would love to see.
Then you'd need extremely precise instrumentation for this,
which I don't think at this point is practical.
But if,
if you were to test,
say the top hundred competitors and determine for any blood marker that's
associated with performance,
who sets the high watermark?
So in other words,
nobody's going to have the same testosterone.
So it's like,
it's not possible that everyone has the same testosterone and free testosterone,
et cetera.
So let's identify a handful of things like free,
let's just say t three free free thyroid.
Um,
then you have free testosterone and uh,
you know,
you could look at proxies for growth hormone and blah,
blah,
blah.
You're like,
okay,
everybody else can dope up to this high watermark and not beyond it if you want,
if you want it to try to level the playing field,
that might be extensively how you'd go about doing it.
I mean,
obviously that's more of a thought exercise.
We'd never had them would never expect it to happen.
But it's like the idea that,
I mean there are people out there who produce testosterone that would be in
excess of what I could achieve with low to low dose testosterone if I were to
inject it right then of course.
Yeah,
it is.
There's no even playing field when it comes to athletics.
Yeah.
There's just not,
you know,
certain people will have a different bone structure.
Certain people,
like John Jones has a massive research reach advantage over almost everyone he
fights.
Are we going to cut people's limbs and stretch them out until they're Jon Jones
is a size to make it even.
Cause if it's not,
then it's not even.
Yeah.
You know,
a guy like,
you know,
certain guys,
I don't know how much you follow the history of MMA,
but there's certain guys that just had a massive advantage or how about
wrestling?
How about Alexander Chlorella?
I thought,
oh fuck.
Graylin is amazing.
You can't overcome that.
You're never going to overcome that.
For those people who don't know who this is.
Yeah.
Alexandria or Alexander Karelian Greco was seven,
six,
seven time world champion Greco Roman wrestler.
Uh,
and,
uh,
I remember having a poster in high school when I was wrestling and one of his
quotes was,
I train harder every day,
then you will ever trained in your life.
And then there was a photograph of him doing his reverse body lift and he was
famous for this is the guy,
you guys have to look this guy up.
He talked about them in the pot.
Oh,
absolutely.
When he was being interviewed by a journalist at one point,
they're like,
aren't you muscle?
Like don't you get muscle bound to get with building your muscles the way that
you,
that you have?
And he lifted his foot up and touched a chandelier over his head and he's like,
no,
not really.
He stretches.
Yeah,
yeah.
That they trained that guy the right way.
They used to call him to experiment because,
uh,
they,
they had,
you know,
he had tiny Fallon a family.
His parents were small.
Yeah.
It's parents white.
Five,
seven,
five,
eight.
Yeah.
I think his dad was five or seven or something like that.
And with Moms,
I,
you know what,
it might have been smaller than that.
Wow.
And for folks who don't know how big he was,
I think he was six,
four,
six,
five,
300 pounds and move like a cat.
He was the most ridiculous athletic specimen that I'd ever seen.
But the reality of that era of the Soviet Union is you got to assume that they
had that guy on everything,
on demand.
The fact that they had women that looked like men in the eastern block,
women,
we had victor content on the podcast who said that those women's set records
that to this day are unattainable in women.
Yeah.
Oh,
I'm totally played it.
That was the,
that was the,
the golden era of drugs.
It was like,
what in the 80s?
Uh,
probably earlier as well.
But I mean,
you look at some of like the female basketball players from the Soviet Union
during the Cold War and it's just like they meant these,
these shelves of bone.
Yeah.
Like acromegaly from Growth Pharma.
Well,
not only that,
they have that man face,
you know,
there's a face that a man has.
Like if I put you in a dress,
okay.
And I put lipstick on you and I'm like,
that motherfucker has on man face.
I don't know what it is,
what it is about a man's face that is just different.
But there's a weird thing that happens to these women.
I thought you were hitting on me from,
I don't know.
How dare you put you in a dress.
If I wanted to have sex with a man,
I would want a man and literally on man.
God Damn it.
You just take it.
Just take it apart.
Anti Parkinson's drug and be done with it.
Yeah.
I would just fucking get on some reequipped and get the party started.
Um,
there's,
there's a,
I don't know,
it's a really hard to tell thing.
I mean,
it's a hard to describe thing.
Like how do you describe subtlety of sarcasm to someone who doesn't understand
language?
Right.
Well,
there's a subtlety to a face that is a man face and I don't know what it is.
It's like a little leaner than it should be.
Like a little,
little more taut.
The jaw muscles seem a little bigger than they should be.
Yeah.
There's a little bit more intensity to you.
What is that a man face that you're pulling up?
Yeah.
That chick from peewee's big adventure scene of a man face.
I need to look up a by email.
Who Man,
no,
that's a sprinter.
Who is,
I guess Hermaphrodite who was recently stripped of her metals in what she was,
she exonerated.
I do not remember the story.
I think that they thought that she was a man and then they actually,
they actually exonerated her when they subjected her to some really humiliating
tests and found out she's just,
you know,
there's a spectrum.
We've all met fame men who are,
you know,
a week and look like they barely produce any testosterone at all.
I don't know why that is.
And then you'll meet a Samoan guy who doesn't even lift weights and he's got
calves,
like somebody cut him open and stuffed up basketball each of his fucking legs.
It doesn't make any sense.
You know,
there's the,
the human body is very variable.
So I think,
um,
the idea of a level playing field as we were talking about.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's preposterous.
There's no level playing and just have to do,
do the most with whatever you are equipped with or wait for science to turn you
into the hulk.
Cause yeah,
cause that to me seems like it's inevitable.
I look at the idea of performance enhancing drugs is always going to exist.
Okay.
The of being
able to take something,
it makes you better and like all things,
it's going to progress.
Like your laptop's computer power processing power,
the processing power of your phone,
the download speeds of your Internet.
All that stuff's going to keep going.
So if it's going to keep going in the athletic department,
you got to go,
okay,
well where's it going to go?
Cause it's not,
it's,
it's gonna.
It's not gonna stop where it's at,
where you get,
you know,
fill in the blank.
Super Athlete.
Michael Johnson,
is that the graph from the Oh no it was,
it got Ben Johnson and Johnson.
It's not going to stop there.
Obviously it didn't.
And by the way they say that when he was stripped of his gold medal,
Carl Lewis was doping.
He was,
he tested positive for at least to a band stimulant.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
that's when the HIA crafty doctors and lawyers at work,
went about creating this inadvertent use explanation.
Herbal tea.
I had a cold,
that's why I tested positive for ephedrine.
But uh,
have you seen bigger,
faster,
stronger?
Yeah.
I haven't seen the whole thing.
I shut it off halfway through.
Okay.
No,
because they interview Carlos,
but then they also interview,
uh,
people from,
I believe it was the International Olympic Committee anti-doping,
uh,
antidoping coalition or whatever the name of it was.
Who,
uh,
who did,
they didn't forge,
but they,
uh,
eh,
they,
they exonerated athletes who tested positive,
who were a PR assets to the United States by effect removing documentation.
Well,
that's essentially what they did with Lance Armstrong,
right?
Yeah,
sure.
I mean,
it's,
uh,
Ben Johnson,
Ben Johnson.
It's too bad.
Like with Ben Johnson for instance.
Um,
like as far as I'm concerned,
look,
if you're going to play a sport,
you break the rules,
you get disqualified and the story.
But he was,
he,
he tested positive for a drug that he was not using.
He was using it different anabolic,
a number one.
Number two was,
uh,
his training by Charlie Francis was absolutely state of the art.
So there's a,
there's a book if I think you have to eat,
I don't really think you could find you have to buy for like 170 bucks,
but it's called a training for speed by Charlie Francis.
That is a gold mine.
Really incredible.
Yeah,
just incredible.
I mean,
this guy was decades ahead.
Uh,
in terms of his,
his training protocols,
really,
really outstanding from a personal,
for a personal question,
what do you know about bulging discs and healing back injuries and dealing with
back injuries?
I don't know.
I don't know much about bulging desks.
Um,
I,
I do know that,
uh,
I've had,
I've just recently fixed some,
some pretty,
uh,
pretty fucking painful back issues.
And,
uh,
I realized after doing a lot of PT and going to some very high end,
sports therapist that my lower traps for instance on my left side weren't firing
properly from a bunch of old injuries and a host of other,
uh,
for a host of other reasons.
And it turned out I tried a number of ways to fix this and x,
there's causing a lot of mid back pain and whatnot.
And it,
uh,
it,
I came to realize that I,
it wasn't enough to just do like activation exercises where I retracted,
depress the Scapula and raise my arm and whatnot.
I actually had to fix pack.
Uh,
I had to increase my pec mobility and open up my chest because of so much time
sitting down at a computer.
I had to use a Lacrosse ball to do mobility work on my pecks and then just like
that,
my,
uh,
my lower traps are firing properly again and now my back stabilized.
I can do kettlebell swings properly.
Uh,
pretty wild.
Have you ever been robbed?
I have,
yeah.
That's quite feeling.
That's supposed to sort of be the whole concept behind the Roth Roth things.
Very helpful.
I also,
uh,
have had some very good results with art active release technique Graston which
is where they use implements to effectively help with,
it's like raw fin with metal objects,
with fundamental objects.
Yeah.
Battle ropes.
That'll respite and they put you on a bad heart first,
uh,
for very good results with that bulging discs.
I don't know enough about to really go on.
Well right now I've been,
rolfing has been helping me alleviate a lot of the feeling of the,
the tension in the muscles around the backwards tighten up Jujitsu injury,
reoccurring injury that the lucky thing is that it's bulging,
it's on herniated,
and apparently there's,
there they have good success and trying to fix that.
I wanted to know if you knew anything about a spinal decompression cause that's
one of the things that people have been,
a lot of people have been suggesting.
There's a lot of it
different using what technique?
Um,
I forget the name of the machine,
but there's a couple of different in this one state of the art one VRX 9,000,
I want to say,
hold on.
Spying.
Um,
there's a place in Beverly Hills.
It does it.
Yeah.
Drx 9,000 spinal decompression and uh,
it's like polls and relaxes and poles and relaxes and does so in a way that the,
um,
uh,
it,
it does it in a varying way where the muscles don't resist it or it's like,
I guess regular if feel like hanging upside down by your ankles,
your muscle musculature would tighten up when it really won't be much separation
at all.
But this does it in a way where it,
it pulls and relaxes multiple times within a second so that it confuses the body
enough so that it doesn't react to it.
And it allows to slowly separate the,
uh,
the injured area and allows the,
a compressed disk to a relax and go back.
Not sure.
Let me know how it goes.
I mean I'd be interested in what I found very helpful for trying to work on
let's say thoracic or upper back issues is trying to address the,
or trying to identify if there are problems lower down.
I like the lumbar and the hip level first.
So for instance,
there's a device you can get,
it's a little quirky,
the exercises rather odd looking but it's called the supine groin progressive
and uh,
the,
it's an Nga,
you exercise Eg,
O,
s,
c,
u e and there's this thing that looks like a tower and you put a boot on
effectively that locks your foot in place and you just extend it and you,
you,
you increase or decrease the elevation and,
and you have one leg in this thing for like 20,
25 minutes at a time and it,
you position your,
your other leg at a right angle.
Anyway,
the point being it eat,
it causes,
at least in me,
it really helped to relax more than anything else.
Extremely tight hip flexors from sitting down for extended periods of time,
which then alleviated the lower back pain.
And then I found a lot of the upstream pains and aches that I had were
apparently referral from lower down.
And that's an issue with Jujitsu guys where you get back pain from tight
hamstrings.
Yup.
Very common that you're,
you as your hamstrings tighten up your back.
We'll sorta like resist and you'll,
you'll start getting like cramps and areas
that might've even initially been where,
why I haven't
my issue in the first place.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean I remember way back in the day I went to the same doctors that worked on
uh,
Bj Penn and they said you didn't do it when you do so much guard work.
ACC,
he had,
they said his hip flexors are like the hip flexors of a fucking camel.
They were like as big around as,
you know,
normal person's quad.
Like his hip flexors are just ridiculous.
And so we had all this debilitating back pain and they focused on art primarily.
But it's like,
yeah,
I mean if you look at the damage it can be done through sitting.
It's like,
well,
if you're doing a lot of guard work like man,
are you shortly near your hip flexors?
Yeah,
guard guys a lot of times of like serious lower back problems and Eddie Bravo so
had some pretty extensive lower back problems.
He's really interesting because he subscribes to that John Sarno ideology that
you didn't know Sarno was a idea is that it's all in your head?
Yeah.
Is a,
what is it like back pain free?
I know I've seen so I've read at least one of his books.
What's your take on it?
I don't,
I think there are many cases where it's in your head.
I think there are also a hell of a lot of cases where there's a structural
problem.
Yeah,
I agree.
100%
I I find that book to be a little insulting.
The idea like you know that he's seen all these different backs that have been
all fucked up and the people haven't been any pain at all.
I'm like,
what are they doing though?
Are they,
are they sprinting?
Are they throwing kettle bells around or are they just like living life and not
moving at all because it's not the case.
Yeah.
You might not be in back pain,
but if you have a structural issue and you try to use your body and know you
have a herniated disc,
you can't fucking tell me that's in your head.
That's craziness.
Yeah.
There I think there are a few things.
I would say that I think that using his method,
you could effectively self hypnotize and block out pain that is due to a
structural problem,
but that doesn't fix the structural issue.
Right.
So I do think that exasperate,
yeah.
Yeah.
Could be exacerbated by the fact that you have a real problem.
Right.
So just having looked at,
and I'm sure you've had plenty of injuries too,
but it's like after
a decade of wrestling and a bunch of judo and this,
that and the other thing and accumulating injuries and fixing those injuries,
like there are points at which you have structural problems that need fixing.
And,
uh,
and um,
yeah,
I think that's pretty much the end of the,
the coil or the beginning of the story is not necessarily the end of the story,
but it's fascinating how many people subscribe to it and how many people say
that it's changed in,
in life and actually help them.
It's,
it's really interesting.
I don't think they're lying.
No.
So it's like what was their pain based on?
Is it okay?
I do.
I do think you also could have a structural pain that you then become so
accustomed to reacting to that you have trouble functioning without envisioning
that pain in some fashion.
Does that make sense?
Yes,
it does.
And I think in those instances,
which I think are,
are probably quite common,
then his approach would be absolutely appropriate and would have a huge impact.
But it's like you can't tell me,
it's like if somebody has a triangle and gets picked up off the ground and,
and the guy tries to do a fucking front flip and slams the guy on his upper back
and his neck that he's just going to meditate is way to feeling better.
It's like,
no,
like you need to get back guys,
Mris,
you need to get some x rays and I don't think sign would disagree with that.
But it's like there are,
there are times that you just need like real interventions whether that's
nutritional or therapeutic or manual manipulation.
Yeah,
I completely agree.
But I do find it fascinating how many people swear by it.
It's,
it's a,
it's an amazing thing.
I mean it was sent to me because I was having back pain and a buddy of mine is
like this is,
this is what fixed me.
And he sent it over there.
Well the issue also is like why the back?
Why not knees?
Why not elbows?
How come it's only in the back and the how w w why did people believe that they
store tension in their back?
Like what is that about?
It's all sitting then think so what it is think cynics terrible for him.
I think it ended well.
Yeah,
I think it is.
Well we just,
I get tired from sitting but I don't get tired like were saying about the
hunting thing.
Walking around on top of mountains everyday.
You don't need an APP.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
no,
not at all.
We're not designed for this.
This is a weird activity.
Just be sitting still and then get our food just comes to us.
We're going to leave here,
we're going to go get some steak with Sam Harris and Kayla.
We're not killing anything,
dude.
We're just sitting down.
It's already killed.
They waited a while,
they aged it and then they're going to cook it right in front of,
we don't have to do shit's give him a little piece of plastic.
Boom.
And they bring us in meat.
I told my,
I told my girlfriend because,
uh,
I get,
I get stuck in my head quite a lot because I'm always like,
I can logic my way out of this.
Like there's gotta be like,
if something's bothering me,
it's cause I'm looking at it the wrong way.
Or like I'm not doing the right thought exercise.
Like I can,
blah,
blah.
And it gets so hyper intellectual about problems that are,
have far simpler solutions typically,
or not typically,
but very often.
So I remember at one point I was just fucking,
Oh shit,
I'm fucking angry about some bullshit that I had to deal with.
Like maybe it was Barnes and noble,
something rather some fucking who knows?
And so I was trying to like meditate my way out of it and I was like,
you know what?
I need to go to the fucking gym and lift some heavy stuff.
And so I just left and like did some dead lifts.
I came back and I just said whenever I'm like trying to figure out stuff by
reading like Krishnamurthy or whatever,
which has its place,
but like send me to the gym first because nine times out of 10 I'll come back
and I'll be fine.
Action has its place as well.
Yeah,
it's very important.
Intellectuals,
oftentimes we'll ignore that aspect of the body.
Mind to an action.
Yeah.
I think it's a real disservice.
They really fucked themselves over by,
you know,
whatever it is,
an association with Jocks,
you know,
whatever it is in their head that makes them not hesitant to commit to training
and exercise.
But God,
it's such a,
you're doing yourself a disservice.
I had lunch with the,
uh,
I think she's the president.
Um,
or one of the heads of the Michael J.
Fox foundation focused on Parkinson's research and drug development and they
have some fantastic scientists involved and we got into this long conversation
about Parkinson's and Alzheimer's in different types of neuro degenerative
disease because I have Parkinson's and Alzheimer's on both sides of my family.
So yeah.
And like I said,
we equipped son get in there.
Don't be scared
to have my friends ready to intervene up to have some like bouncers from the
Jerry Springer show.
Those guys in the black shirts keep an eye on me.
They might take advantage of me though.
They might
give you the double up your dosage,
but the,
the point I was going to make,
I said,
I asked her of all the,
all the prospective drugs,
all of the potential interventions,
let's say,
I do think I wasn't kidding about creating and coconut oils,
medium chain triglycerides,
pretty interesting applications to staving off things like Alzheimer's and
Parkinson's.
And that's not just like bullshit anecdote.
Like it's actually been some decent research,
uh,
applied to it,
but she said exercise exercise number one
totally makes sense.
Yeah,
for sure.
It has a massive effect on my mood and my self esteem,
my,
my perception of the world,
my tolerance for people.
Everything.
Yeah.
It's gotta be good for you.
You fucks get out there and exercise at the end of this long and beautiful
podcast about really important issues.
It's really all about do calisthenics,
get some chin ups and you'll look at life better.
It's true.
Do some high rep squats against some perspective.
Yeah.
Do a hundred body weight squats.
Just a hundred.
You know,
Karl gotch used to make people do 500 bodyweight squats.
Gotchas base.
Yeah.
He's to have you,
you'd have to go through like some crazy rigorous thing for like over a year
before he would even show you wrestling.
Louis,
you'd have to get yourself in shape first.
Sorry.
Japanese about the whole thing.
Yeah.
Is that what it is?
It's the Japanese ideology and they fell in love with him.
Yeah.
Man.
When I was in Japan 92 they had all sorts of profiles of him.
Oh really?
Very much.
Like,
okay,
you want to make Sushi?
Great.
You're going to learn how to,
how to steam rice for 10 years,
and then I'm going to let you touch your first fish.
You know,
it's very like pay your dues.
Have you seen Jiro Dreams of Sushi?
No,
I heard it's amazing.
Oh Man.
You were like the seventh person on Netflix.
It is as it or I'm going to watch it tonight.
I went to Japan,
uh,
and had Sushi with his son after seeing that movie because I wanted to check out
exactly how they made it a for the four hour chef.
And I was looking also at sort of longevity questions.
So I went to,
okay,
now into the village where they have the average,
the longest average lifespan in the world.
Oh me.
It's in the middle of nowhere to try to look at like their diet,
what they did,
how they behaved,
et Cetera.
I think one of the advantages I have is there a lot of people who have looked
into that.
Number one,
going with a confirmation bias that they're like,
all right,
these people are vegetarians and they come in with a thesis they want to prove
as accurate and there were a couple of really fascinating thanks.
Number one.
Uh,
right off the bat I noticed that you could look at the things they do that other
people don't do it.
So they drink fermented turmeric tea for instance.
Very,
very common.
Who knows if that's the,
that's the culprit or the cause.
It's probably a combination of factors,
but one of the things was we very rarely got rice with our meals.
Traditional looking now and meals.
We've got sweet potatoes,
very low price,
and they actually had a lot of pork and pork fat for instance.
But the perhaps the most important thing that I took away from this,
almost nobody retires.
Our driver was 85 and he had more energy than all of us combined and he's like,
yeah,
let me show you.
I'll get out,
I'll walk out.
I'll show you around.
Like everybody was,
they had a purpose.
They still had some type of purpose.
Even if that was just like tending the fields of irises on the outskirts of Ogi
me or whatever it was like they are out and about doing things.
Um,
yeah.
It just stands to reason that if the body doesn't get exercise,
it atrophies.
If the muscles don't get exercise,
they shrank the,
if the mind doesn't get any stimulation,
it becomes dull.
It's like it just you,
you got to use it or it goes away.
It's really,
you don't own it for very long and the only way it works right is if you have
fucking put the pedal to the medal and keep that bitch hot.
Stress the organism,
stress the organism people.
But the Jiro dreams of Sushi,
you'll,
I think you'll really enjoy it.
I have to see this is,
yeah,
we got to wrap this up because this is for real.
This is,
you're the seventh person,
I think in this past week that's this brought up that movie seven again.
That was an accident.
Actually.
I just slipped right out.
It might even be hyperbole.
It might've been five and I said seven because it'd been hypnotized.
What are your favorite movies?
I know we've got to wrap,
but I'm very curious.
I favorite movies,
documentaries or,
or,
or let's,
uh,
if,
if they come to mind,
I'd love to know documentaries.
Grizzly man.
That's one of my favorite because I love the unintentional comedy.
I think grizzly man is one of the perfect movies.
That's Werner Herzog.
Yeah.
Werner Herzog's movie about a guy who was gay who didn't want to be gay,
so he lived with bears.
I mean,
that's how I take it.
And then he quite a gnarly ending too.
Yeah.
Suicide by bear.
It's a hundreds and hundreds of hours this guy took.
If you haven't seen the grizzly man,
it's a must.
See,
it's really one of my all time favorite movies and it's hilarious if you see it
with the right person under the right.
Herbs and supplements,
I think Glaucoma medication,
Aisha.
Yeah,
exactly that too.
It's fucking tremendous.
It's a,
it's probably one of my,
cause I,
it has everything to it as nature and animals,
which I'm absolutely obsessed with.
Scary fucking grizzly bears.
It's why your,
your episode of meeting here.
Oh fuck.
It was horrifying.
She's he,
you haven't seen it Brian?
He was out there with a fucking,
they had,
they killed a Caribou,
which is,
okay,
so you've got like 400 pounds of meat sitting there.
Yeah.
And a grizzly bear rand into your camp.
He was a running towards
the key,
had three separate grizzly encounters with the grizzlies coming into our camps.
All right.
Ooh.
How dangerous is that?
Is it really dangerous,
sort of dangerous?
I they,
well,
Steve would give you a different answer,
but I think that's moderately dangerous.
Fucking mediators and a pile of meat right next to your total,
you would feel like they would just eat that meat,
but maybe not.
It would be more appealing to them.
But here's the thing,
they're pretty curious,
right?
When you see things that haven't existed on the landscape or they'll look really
peculiar.
They have no fear of humans because they don't associate gunshot and human with
anything bad.
Or they don't associate humans with anything bad.
At least they associate humans with free gut pile.
Right.
If anything,
so the wind,
because the hunters will leave behind the gut pile.
So when I see humans,
so they hear gunshots and they go smell something pretty interesting and then
they see humans and they're like gut pile.
It's just like a gunshot.
Actually my draw them in.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Not In this particular case though,
the
death squad shirt by Tim Ferriss through that.
Amen.
I do what I can.
I made my week.
That's awesome.
The was awesome,
but we had a bear come into our camp and we,
we weren't filming this.
I was really upset.
On one hand they were not filming and then on the other hand I was really glad
they were fucking paying enough attention.
Steve was taken like a 20 minute power nap as he's wanting to do in his,
in his tent and this bear wanders over and it's literally like 20 feet away from
his 10th just sniffing around and we're all on the other side of camp and we're
like Steve Fucking grizzly bear.
And it turned out he heard us and he's like,
I'm not going to fucking pop out of that thing like a jack in the box and have a
scare the shit out of a grizzly bear.
He's like to the,
of a gun in the tent with them.
I don't think he did.
Whoa.
So what do you do when the bears that close?
Well,
what he did,
because then we had more bears coming to the camp.
Like the one that you saw sprinting into the camp,
uh,
ran over us or waving his arms,
shot a shotgun in the air.
So like,
but the one that was 20 feet away,
that could have been a real problem.
Right?
I mean,
after the fact.
So Yannis,
I don't know if you met young,
how'd you stop the bear when it was 20 feet away?
What he was probably,
it was probably a hundred feet away.
But the point being like,
it doesn't make a difference.
I mean,
got close.
They're extremely fast.
So to close the distance,
it's like if you have to re chamber around your fucking toast,
you know what I mean?
Uh,
but Steve was very nonchalant about it.
But what I found so funny and it gives you a real perspective,
it's like things like New York City really stressed you out.
You know what I mean?
Like traffic and stuff.
He gets very anxious about it.
Then you were sitting on the side of a lake in the middle of fucking nowhere,
like five hours flight time north of Fairbanks and there's a grizzly bear
charging at a camp and he found out that his cell phone had had been,
had fallen into a pool of insect repellent and they'd broken.
He couldn't turn it on.
He's like,
Fuck God dammit,
my cell phone.
This is the third cell phone had broken him,
whatever.
He's so pissed and that there's a bear running into Kevin.
I'm just like Steve,
a bear bear bear.
And he's just like my fucking fun.
And Jesus,
it was running in to this that it is not a joke.
No,
not a joke.
I was like,
this is really indicative of like a different set of world,
like life experiences.
And then he's like,
all right,
all right.
And he gets up and he's like,
Whoa,
runs towards us or shooting the shotgun and runs away.
He's like,
all right.
Anyway,
where
was that?
You had a Alex Honnold on the podcast yesterday and he's the Free Solo climber
that,
oh,
does those,
and he was just like,
yeah,
it's no big deal when I do it.
No big deal.
Like,
you know,
like we were talking about one thing that he climbed and he's like,
well it's,
it's really not that big a deal.
It's like,
you know,
people have climbed.
I was the first person to solo it,
but people have climbed it.
What do you mean you're the first person you mean?
No one in the human race has ever climbed this shit without a rope,
but you,
and it's not a big deal to him.
It was sad.
It's not a big deal.
I was,
I'm the only person to ever do it,
but whatever the fuck are you talking about,
whatever to any other human being,
like you're talking about something thousands of feet in the sky,
you're climbing up.
It's like walking on the moon by on their own planet.
He was talking about one time when we climbed up and he was halfway,
he was on his way up and he realized he forgot his chalk bag,
how to keep going.
So he got to a ledge.
There's a famous ledge where some campers,
where were other hikers were there,
who were,
uh,
taking a nap because it takes days for them to go up with ropes.
This motherfucker is doing with no ropes so that he can kind of borrow some
chalk or we got some chalk and then climbed up to the top with it.
They're like,
what the fuck is this guy doing?
Could you imagine you're camped out on a ledge?
And he said,
by the way,
the ledge is half the size of this desk.
Okay,
so there's two tents,
two different camps on this ledge.
He climbs up there and he's like,
can I get some chalk?
And I'm like,
yeah,
here's some shock.
Thanks.
And he's climbing up the rest of the lab stuff.
And that's normal to him.
You know,
that makes me feel like such a pussy.
But we brought up porn stars and the kid basically shit his pants.
You see that?
That brought yet?
Do you want to go?
Yeah.
I just need to know though.
Yeah,
come on,
let's go.
I'll give you a ticket and have some fun,
man.
It was a big UFC too.
Um,
but he,
he,
you know,
Brian Dates Porn stars upon occasion,
basically steady diet now.
But,
um,
it can't go backwards.
He,
uh,
when he,
when he found out on the Alex,
John was like,
really?
Okay.
Do you know porn stars all of the sudden
disappeared.
Eyebrows went up.
He was still shocked.
And we,
we found that there was a very important moment because a very important moment
where like,
oh,
because his comfort zone and talking about death defying feats of,
of,
you know,
keeping your shit together under pressure climbing without a fucking chalk bag,
1500 feet in the sky.
That was nothing to him just the other day at the office.
No know,
oh girl has sex for living.
Oh Gee,
golly.
He might've not had it in his pants with Brian's descriptions and he probably
won't want to go to Mexico because I guess that area that he,
he's going to climb I guess like 16 people just got murdered there the other
day.
Like the town that he's going to,
are you sure?
Yeah.
Somebody was sent me on Twitter.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Well maybe he doesn't know that yet because he hasn't read the Internet.
Right.
And Kid,
he doesn't,
he never watched a TV show.
He lives in a van down by the river in a van.
She looked like Moab or something.
Well he just travels around going to different places to climb.
Yeah,
he gets like,
I guess he has like a bank account somewhere.
He has sponsors.
They send him some money.
He doesn't need much cause he lives in a van.
Really fascinating.
The kid were dragging him.
Can you,
can you get some hookers?
Pretty girls that uh,
you know,
have loose morals.
So that's what I'm trying to say.
I don't mean like actual hookers.
Real hookers.
Don't do,
we can do whatever you got,
but brings,
bring some girls that,
uh,
that know how to party.
All right,
let's,
let's throw Alex to the wolves.
All right.
Listen man,
there's fucking another awesome podcast.
We should do
it.
This is great.
And I love sad that we have to stop game of Thrones table.
She'll miss you.
Shit,
isn't it?
I love it.
Yeah.
I'm really happy when we had this,
uh,
made.
It's,
it's awesome dude.
You're the fucking shit man.
We,
every time you're in here,
we have amazing conversations.
We could do this forever and ever and ever.
Um,
uh,
four hour chef is the most recent one.
Only available at Amazon through your website is the four hour chef.
You can go to a four hour blog.com.
All these places you can get tons of sample chapters,
the whole nine yards.
Beautiful.
Ah,
if anybody wants to follow you on Twitter,
it's Tim Ferris,
f e R R,
I s.
S t Ferriss.
Tim Ferriss.
Not Yes.
T.
Okay.
Don't go to Tim Ferris.
Is there an actual Tim Ferris?
I have.
I have that one as well.
Oh,
that's you too.
As long as I tweeted you,
but it's the wrong one.
This is Tim Ferriss character.
I look and it says listening,
reading,
talking.
Oh,
nevermind.
That's probably my way to wisdom.
That's probably with one ass.
I imagine this is some other motherfucker.
Yeah,
I gave the wrong motherfucker.
God dammit.
Twitter.
You guys going to get a Twitter bot?
Thanks.
Okay.
Sorry.
I fucked up.
I'm going gonna write this down.
I fucked up the real,
what are you doing?
Don't do that dude.
You going to get us kicked off of Youtube?
You fuck the real Tim Ferris at t Ferris,
double r double s Twitter.
We're going to be in West Palm Beach next week as we are tickets are available
at [inaudible] dot com I believe.
Uh,
yes,
that'd be fine.
Yeah.
We're going to have a good time.
It's a Joey Diaz,
Brian and I and a.
We're going to be,
it's a huge place.
It's a lot of fun,
but it's selling fast.
It's almost sold out.
So,
uh,
get in there.
You're dirty bitches.
Um,
West Palm Beach Improv.
Go to [inaudible].
Dot.
Got to go Google.
You could find it,
but yeah,
we're going to have a good time.
That's a fun place to do.
Stand up.
They're crazy.
You should have a fucking passport to go to Miami.
That area.
That'll air.
They,
they're nutty.
If they know how to party in this Oxycontin's everywhere,
we'll hope.
Hopefully we'll keep it together for the entire weekend.
And uh,
we're also going to Vegas this weekend.
Um,
the West,
uh,
what am I talking about?
West Palm Beach next weekend.
This weekend we're at Mandalay bay.
Uh,
Brian Callan is joining us.
First Time Brian's ever come on the road with us.
So it's Brian,
Ari,
me,
Brian Booboo,
red bands going to be there with hookers and Alex Honnold not hunger.
It's not really hunger.
It's just girls who have money that they give them.
Sometimes they have sex,
but that's not a worker.
That's what they do,
right?
They're porn.
They're not hookers.
No.
But they get money for sex and a classically in the Bible,
I think that makes a hooker,
but they didn't have the Internet back then,
so fuck them.
Right performance artists,
performance artists,
thanks to hover.com if you go to hover.com forward slash,
Rogan,
you will get 10% off your domain name registrations.
Thank you also to onnit.com if you use the code named Brogan,
you will save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right?
Yeah,
Fox,
we will see you tomorrow with the real Rick Ross.
Not that rapper dude who just got his car shot up,
but the actual real Rick Ross,
allegedly,
it's going to be a very interesting,
allegedly.
Yeah,
50 cent doesn't believe it really happened,
but I believe very few people make a joke and shoot at a Rolls Royce.
That's just me though.
I don't think that's worth it for.
Listen,
the money that you're going to get out of that story,
what the fuck do I know about Bobo's thing?
All right,
we'll see you guys tomorrow.
Go Fuck Yourself.